it's the late 90s and an Air Canada
flight experiences severe malfunctions
while traveling from London to Vancouver
the pilots are unable to do anything and
the plane crashes into the woods of
Northern Alberta the crash was
devastating only 10 of the nearly 300
people on board are alive and even
though they survived the initial
disaster their battle for life has only
just begun it's late autumn in Northern
Canada and there's no telling when help
will arrive if at all if the survivors
want to make it through the night they
need to find shelter and fast as they
trudge through the freezing Woods the
group finds a path that looks like it
might lead them to civilization after
all if there was a path in the woods
that meant they were probably in a
national park and if they were in a
national park there had to be a ranger
station around somewhere where they
could warm up and call for help they
didn't have many other options so they
followed the path which opened up to a
clearing but instead of finding a ranger
station or Campground they found
something none of them could have
expected it was a pawn but there was
something off about it as they got
closer they saw that this strange Pond
wasn't filled with water but blood the
survivors were horrified that couldn't
really be blood could it it must have
been a weird algae or chemical reaction
but one member of the group a man named
Thomas Dean who had been on his way back
to his hometown of Prince George British
Columbia thought there was something
strangely familiar about this he
remembered being a boy and going to
visit family in Alberta and hearing an
urban legend from the older local kids
according to the stories somewhere out
in the wilderness in the northern part
of the province there was a pond full of
human blood and what made it even worse
was that some said the pond was a
gateway to Hell the SCP Foundation was
also aware of this Legend and had been
trying to pinpoint the exact source of
it for decades prior to the Air Canada
crash they would finally receive
definite confirmation of the blood Pond
when Foundation person L intercepted a
radio transmission from a ranger station
located within the Wood Buffalo national
park it was the survivors of the crash
who had managed to make it through the
night and they were about to be escorted
out of the park by Rangers the
foundation mobilized quickly to cordon
off the pond as at the time they were
unsure of what potentially harmful
properties the pond might have had they
set up watch station Epsilon 38 and put
staff on guard to deter travelers from
the area the pond was given the
designation of scp-354 and classed as
Euclid Foundation scientists made a
number of interesting discoveries about
scp-354 when they collected samples for
testing first the pond was not in fact
full of blood merely an inorganic liquid
that closely resembles blood in color
and consistency second and even Stranger
Than The Red liquid is that the pond
doesn't seem to have any definite Banks
or a bottom instead the liquid in the
pond increases in density as the radius
away from the center increases the
liquid congeals at the edge becoming
more solid and blending into the
surrounding soil it also becomes thicker
as one descends deeper into the pool and
the bottom of the pond has not yet been
reached if it even exists initially the
foundation found no signs of life within
the blood Pond but that would all change
at 203 pm on the day following the
opening of Watch Station Epsilon 38 when
the science team noticed an unusual
level of activity on the Pond's surface
security footage feeds showed a shape
rising out of the pond followed by a
deafening shriek after that the feed was
cut and Foundation lost all
communication with watch station Epsilon
30A fearing the worst a mobile task
force was dispatched to the location
when they got there all Personnel at the
watch station had been killed by what
could only be described as a gigantic
bat the task force was able to
neutralize the entity and as soon as
they could the foundation moved in to
increase security around the SCP
creating area 354 and installing a
permanent security detail after this
point the pond started to regularly spit
out a variety of monstrous entities
almost as if it was reacting to the SCP
foundation's increased security measures
after
scp-354-1 the giant bat came
scp-354-2
354-2 was an echidna-like monster the
size of a bear that was virtually
bulletproof but unable to escape area
354. the foundation neutralized this
anomaly with Napalm
scp-354-3 was a floating black sphere
capable of firing deadly beams of
concentrated energy the area's head
scientists was able to hit it with a
sledgehammer causing the sphere to
malfunction and self-destruct before it
was able to escape the area the
foundation wasn't as lucky with
scp-354-4 this creature was a reptilian
humanoid that stood roughly 15 feet tall
and was unable to be put down with
gunfire this was the first Creature from
the pond to successfully Escape
containment and was only able to be
neutralized when the foundation sent in
Mobile task force omega-7 a also known
as Pandora's Box the data on Pond
incursions is partially corrupted so a
complete list of creatures is not
available but some of the other monsters
that came out of the blood Pond include
a killer robot a set of gigantic
tentacles that drag several d-class
Personnel into the pond a pair of
panther-like creatures one made of ice
and the other of magma that ignored
Foundation staff and instead fought each
other and one seemingly normal human man
who was executed as soon as he emerged
from the pond tests on his body revealed
that he was in fact totally normal and
would have posed no threat these
anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months
before the pond went silent for an
unprecedented 22 months the head
scientists at the time noted I suspect
this means one of two things either the
red pool has died or powered down or
whatever the correct term for it is or
is charging up for something big to come
through o5 believes the former is the
most likely explanation and has recalled
30 of our total personnel and cut 25
percent of our funding while I can only
hope that they are correct if the latter
situation is true we're soon to face
some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary
to deal with it I worry for all of our
safety his words would prove eerily
prophetic following the events of
exploratory Mission 354 Alpha the
foundation's research and development
team built a specialized craft to
explore the pond because of the strange
properties of the Pond's density the
craft was essentially made to be both a
submarine for parts of the pond where
the contents were liquid and a drill for
when the liquid congealed into a
semi-solid towards the bottom the
exploration team consisted of agent
Swanson agent turquoise agent 86 Dr J
McArthur Chris Simmons Leroy Tucker and
a pilot named Mark with the team
assembled the ship was sent down into
the pond nothing eventful happen for the
first two days of the mission but at 4
30 a.m on the third day gravity suddenly
reversed for the crew of the shim this
seemed to indicate that they were
approaching the halfway point though
what would be on the other side nobody
could say on the fourth day the ship
surfaced proving definitely that the
pond was in fact some sort of portal the
crew looked out of the portholes to see
the darkness of night above them while
sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them the crew were wary of exiting the
craft the other side of the pond was
nothing like the world the crew knew for
one thing the night lasted for 28 hours
before Don came and when the Sun finally
Rose it was much larger and redder than
the Earth's sun under the light of the
strange red star the crew could see that
the pond on this side was massive
compared to what they've come into more
like a large lake surrounding the lake
was sand and rocks that were covered in
a kind of moss that disappeared under
sunlight and regrew during the night the
team left the ship and started to
explore during their time in This
Strange World they found that the day
lasted just a few hours shorter than the
night meaning that whatever Planet they
were on had a roughly 43 hour long
rotation as opposed to our own planet's
24. the team found a number of anomalous
elements on their expedition including
racer sharp grass that can puncture skin
and streams of liquid carbon dioxide
they heard some loud Roars in the
distance once or twice but other than
that the planet was eerily silent with
seemingly no animal life and not even
wind when it rained the soil remained
dry and based on that the scientists
theorized the plants in this world were
more efficient at absorbing moisture on
the 25th day the team ran into a huge
metal wall that appeared to be
artificially constructed luckily Leroy
Tucker a quick thinking researcher was
able to rig a blowtorch from camping
supplies and melt a hole through the
metal on the other side there was
finally wind and odd black grass that's
the extent of what is known about the
other side of the wall because the
Expedition logs are heavily corrupted
after that point but we know that
whatever was in there wasn't good
because the team never returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log almost as if
being killed on the other side
completely erased them from history no
other Expeditions into the pond were
launched after that on an undisclosed
day a year following the discovery of
the blood Pond and construction of area
354. the site was completely evacuated
and power was cut to the area mobile
task force data 12 was dispatched to
investigate the cause of the evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhead was
detonated completely destroying the site
MTF Theta 12 was then attacked by a
convoy made up of d-class and other
low-ranking staff who had evacuated area
354. it was apparent that there had been
some kind of mutiny within the site and
that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction the Convoy totally
annihilated MTF Theta 12 and no further
contact with the former Personnel of
area 354 has been made since following
the site's detonation a new site was
constructed called simply the red pool
containment site unlike the previous
facility which focused on research and
neutralization the new site is entirely
concerned with containment the shift and
directive came as a response to the
Pond's apparent reactive nature each
creature that emerged from the pond
seemed to be in retaliation to the
foundation's actions and it was
theorized by some that the Mutiny at
area 354 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself an
interview in the SCP file on 354 reveals
that there was one more disastrous
attempt to control and understand the
blood Pond according to an interview
with a foundation agent the head doctor
proposed a scheme to drain the blood
Pond using a system of pumps and hoses
all non-essential Personnel were
evacuated in case of emergency leaving
only the pump technicians d-class
personnel and a few agents for security
however as soon as the pump was
scheduled to be turned on everyone at
the side experienced a mass dissociative
episode the agent described the feeling
they all experienced as like being in a
dream and suddenly realizing that you're
asleep he said everything stopped being
real it was like we had to Escape right
now when asked what happened when the
pump was turned on he simply explained
that it wouldn't let them this interview
confirmed the theory that the pond is
not only capable of releasing monsters
out into our world but also that it's
capable of powerful but much more subtle
psychological attacks this suggests a
chilling possibility that the pond isn't
just blindly reacting to being attacked
but it's fully sentient and the actions
of the SCP Foundation have only served
to annoy it and worst studies of the
ponds banks have proved evidence that
the area of congealed liquid around the
perimeter of the pond has been steadily
expanding that's right the pond is
getting bigger the last thing the
foundation agent stationed at the site
said before being dragged out of the
interview and sedated was it gets bigger
and stronger every day and now we've
made it Angry one of the primary aims of
the s CP Foundation is to contain the
anomalies that they discover secure
contain protect is their mission
statement after all however there are
some forces so unknowable and malevolent
that there is no way to truly contain
them
scp-4205 is one such Force
very little is known about
scp-4205 even compared to other scps
many of which are mysterious by their
very nature we do not know what it is we
do not know what it wants and we do not
have any meaningful way to stop it the
best that can be done to protect
yourself from it is to implement the few
known preventative measures available
and pray that it doesn't set its sights
on you the little information that
exists on
scp-4205 was recorded by Wade Dallas a
former Junior researcher at the
foundation he wrote the initial report
on
scp-4205 on a computer terminal 4 though
his work was highly valuable and
provided many previously unknown
insights about the nature of the SCP
sadly his knowledge could not save him
the official entry on
scp-4205 was his final act before his
death on December 11
1992. before we get deeper into that
entry and Wade's final day on Earth it's
important to understand what
scp-4205 is or at least understand the
little we know about what it is 4205 is
a cutter class SCP meaning that it's
incredibly difficult or complicated to
contain it also shows extreme hostility
toward all life it is described as an
amber colored pair of human-like eyes
with the ability to appear spontaneously
in Windows mirrors or any other glass or
glass-like Surface one of the reasons so
little is known about these eyes is that
anyone who sees them dies within seconds
much like the mythical basilisk the Gaze
of
scp-4205 is deadly and inescapable the
eyes only seem to appear to people who
are alone in a room and never in places
where there's more than one person but
aside from that there is no way to
predict where the eyes will appear since
it is unknown if the eyes are part of a
corporeal body or even present on this
line of reality there is no way to
contain them or stop them from killing
this brings us to that fateful day
December 11 1992 the day that the SCP
Foundation would finally be given some
tangible information on the mysterious
Amber eyes at the cost of one of their
researchers lives
Wade Dallas a young man fresh out of his
university studies was brought on board
as a junior researcher by Dr Mark
Forsyth a senior researcher Dr Forsyth
recruited Wade after giving a guest
lecture at his university and being
impressed by Wade's Keen observational
skills thirst for knowledge of The
Unexplained and determination to
understand that which seemed to defy
explanation after Wade graduated he was
recruited by Dr Forsyth and given the
position of Junior researcher at the SCP
Foundation where he assisted Dr Forsyth
now a site supervisor in his research
after several months of working under Dr
Forsyth with minimal responsibilities
Wade was finally given the opportunity
to write his first SCP report on
scp-4205 following some initial
documented appearances of 4205 Dr
Forsyth approved further research into
the anomaly with Wade appointed as the
lead researcher on the subject according
to Wade's entry he was responsible for
the discovery of
scp-4205 when he spotted the anomaly in
a window the later reviews of security
footage determined that he was not the
first person to observe the eyes he did
claim to be the first to observe them
and live to tell the tale
in his writing on the subject weight is
puzzled by the fact that he survived his
encounter with
scp-4205 and wonders what could have set
him apart from the others that fell
victim to its gaze he found himself
frustrated as he documented
scp-4205 his rough drafts of reports
dissolving into angry rants about his
own incompetence Wayne had difficulty
adjusting to his new responsibilities
especially with the added element of his
assigned subject's mysterious and
volatile nature in between his reports
on
scp-4205 its previous appearances and
its effects on its victims he wrote
letters to his father desperate for
reassurance that he was not messing
everything up letters that would sadly
go unsent in his coverage of
scp-4205 Wade made note of a troubling
reoccurring element in each victim's
death when medical professionals
attempted to revive the victims it was
always noted that their brain activity
stopped much more quickly than in cases
of death by natural causes when examined
all aspects of the body aside from the
brain were completely unharmed the brain
however showed massive nerve damage in
the amygdala hippocampus medial temporal
lobe and occipital lobe the appearance
of this brain trauma had been compared
to the effects of electrical shock or
severe head injury in addition to wade
six other people on record encountered
scp-4205 every encounter ended the same
way with sudden brain death and severe
nerve damage immediately after viewing
the eyes in a reflective surface the
first encounter occurred on January 5th
1990 when Deputy liaison Genna viewed
the eyes in a reflective glass one-way
window security tape reveals that the
eyes appeared in the window eight
minutes before the deputy liaison
spotted them as soon as he did he fell
from his chair and immediately died
though the specifics varied from case to
case the end result of every encounter
was the same with none surviving long
enough to relate what they had
experienced every encounter except Wades
as he continued his documentation of SCP
4205 Wade's mental state quickly began
to deteriorate the process of his mind
coming apart and his thoughts giving way
to confusion fear and anger at his own
Survival is documented in his reports on
the SCP he agonized over the questions
of why he was able to survive gazing
into the eyes of
scp-4205 when so many others had not the
question consumed him until he was
unable to eat sleep or do anything but
obsess over the SCP he was tasked with
researching as he became more agitated
he began to write about the eyes
appearing to him again on one occurrence
he attempted to touch them and describe
the sensation like touching a balloon to
your arm after it had been charged with
static electricity he continued to
report seeing the eyes the worse was
when trying to sleep during which he was
overtaken by violent sleep paralysis and
plagued with visions of the Amber eyes
the only comfort Wade seemed to find was
in memories of his loved ones he wrote
about his mother and his father even as
their memories grew foggier to him he
also mentioned a man by the name of
Theodore Quail who he claimed was a
researcher at the foundation later
fact-checking determined that this was
not the case and that Quail must have
been someone from Wade's past he wrote
about quail wistfully mournfully with
words of love and loss tormented by the
sense that he was losing his grip on
reality and everything he once held dear
as Wade descended deeper into a hell
inside his own mind he continued to mull
over the questions of
scp-4205 was there more to it than what
was visible did it have a body why had
he survived the encounter with it and
what did it want from him he decided
that those who had perished immediately
were the lucky ones they had escaped the
torture that had overtaken his life the
eyes were everywhere now watching him
even as he attempted to unlock their
secrets on a foundation computer he
spoke to the eyes at one point but
refused to write down what they said to
him his last entry his last thought was
a plea for Theodore quail's embrace
there is no more written about the
research or about the eyes only a simple
desperate need for a comfort that is
long lost now is the part of our story
where Terror meets tragedy contrary to
what Wade thought and what was recorded
in his final computer entries
he did not survive his brief brush with
scp-4205 the truth is that he spotted
the Amber eyes and the glass above his
terminal monitor while recording the
entry and died seconds later though his
death was Swift it felt agonizingly slow
as revealed by his descent into panic
and paranoia recorded in his writings
the entries recorded as a result of the
connection weighed in the computer his
physical contact with it at the moment
of exposure to
scp-4205's anomalous effects allowing
the terminal to Archive his final
thoughts before he succumbed to the
deadly nature of the eyes the entries
were never physically typed but rather
jumped from his dying mind into the
Mainframe his entries The Echoes of a
Dying mind offer a glimpse into the way
that
scp-4205 kills its victims in the
seconds leading up to death the Amber
eyes fast forward a person's mind
feeding on the electrical impulses that
it gives off as it speeds through what
seems to be days of fear and of a
loosening grip on reality the death may
be swift but the suffering is long Wade
left the foundation with a digital
fingerprint an echo of the person he was
at his core in addition to his
experiences with
scp-4205 itself Wade spent his final
moments terrified for his life dreaming
of a father that he missed and a long
lost love from his college days his
sacrifice must not be forgotten because
no one ever survives an encounter with
scp-4205 his documented final moments
are the only first-hand account in
existence Junior researcher Wade dalitz
gave us a gift in death he allowed the
SCP Foundation a glimpse into the true
horror of the Amber eyes and a reminder
of what they are capable of stealing
from us so be careful of Windows mirrors
screens and all reflective surfaces when
you look into them you never know know
what you might see looking back
the year is 1941 and the world is
gripped by the most violent and
widespread war in history Millions
marched to War as bloody battles are
fought across the globe horrendous
atrocities are carried out on groups of
people and parts of London are bombed to
Rubble on a weekly basis considering
it's only been 20 years since the last
World War it must seem to the early
residents of the early 20th century that
the world is coming apart at the seams
and amongst the chaos it'd be easy not
to notice a secluded Manor House in the
English Countryside disappearing Without
a Trace for 11 days before suddenly
returning to our reality but thankfully
one organization makes it its sole duty
to notice the unnoticeable and
understand the impossible the SCP
Foundation and within that anomalous
manor house foundation agents and
researchers were about to find Horrors
Beyond even their darkest imaginations
this is the Grim tale of
scp-1461 better known as The House of
the worm when the manor house reappeared
after its 11-day absence the foundation
zeroed in sending agents inside to
investigate it was a two-level dwelling
complete with 12 bedrooms four baths
three studies a main foyer slash
Ballroom a library a kitchen and a
pantry basement the foundation observed
that a number of these rooms had been
fitted with rows of bunk beds similar to
a boarding house or Barracks only later
would they understand why they found
that the upper portion of the home
exhibited no abnormal qualities
whatsoever but as the agents
investigated further they found an
entrance to the truly anomalous portion
of the manor the extensive sub-level
system no previous records of the
building kept by the local Council
indicated that there would be anything
below the Manor's basement so either the
mysterious previous occupants who were
nowhere to be found had built sub level
or it just appeared here on its own
regardless of which was the case agents
and researchers knew that whatever had
happened down here had everything to do
with the manners mysterious
disappearance they descended into the
depths of what seemed like a man-made
Cave System constructed primarily from a
mix of concrete iron and Brass it was a
behemoth of 20th century technology
intricate snaking systems of pipes gears
and pumping Pistons it was like someone
had built an entire Factory down here
but for what the agents began to spread
out through the Labyrinthian bowels of
the manor hoping to find some answers
but all they seemed to discover was more
questions this place hadn't been built
with any form of comprehensible logic it
was full of dead ends stairways that
ascended and descended to Nowhere doors
that would open to reveal just walls
behind them were not open at all it was
like a maze built by a maniac it didn't
help that it looked like the place was
recently hit by an earthquake with some
passages caved in and mangled Machinery
strewn about it seemed that no human
workers had interfered with the
impossibly complex and bizarre Machinery
in quite some time a number of the
materials used to construct said
Machinery as well as the gray Sandstone
filling in the collapsed passageways
remain unidentified to this day already
the sub-level was proving to be a
complex puzzle box with only an
estimated 75 percent of its layout
ultimately being mapped by Foundation
researchers however they would soon
realize that this place wasn't just
confusing it was deadly the only method
of self-maintenance detected by the
exploring agents were pipes that would
fire a thick black lubricant onto the
surrounding Machinery one of the
foundation agents had The Misfortune of
getting covered in it while exploring a
darkened passageway and 80 of his body
was melted as a result it appeared that
the viscous black goo was incredibly
corrosive to all organic matter a number
of the machines also emitted dangerously
High quantities of gamma and x-ray
radiation making it difficult to explore
many of the caverns without heavy Hazmat
protection and worst of all were the
extremely hostile creatures living in
the caves who would regularly attack
Foundation Personnel these Abominations
came to be known as
scp-1461-1 vicious SteamPunk
Frankenstein monsters once human but
with large parts of their bodies were
placed by crude mechanical implants
including metal teeth and Claws
1461-1s have displayed a taste for human
flesh and they have dragged multiple
Foundation agents down into their Lair
to be converted into monsters like them
it's believed that
scp-1461 is capable of controlling these
bees through the Strategic use of sound
from its brass-speaking pipes leading
them into areas where Foundation
Personnel are present to instigate
conflict many of these pitiful creatures
have had their throats replaced by
phonographs endlessly repeating the same
nonsense phrases over and over again I
am what you have made me I am choice and
I am tyranny forgive me I am then and I
am now what gods they will be then I am
evil and I am flesh I am the Trap I am
Beauty and I am chaos children are
selfish I am the worm I have broken God
still in spite of The Mazes monsters and
deadly chemicals the agents persisted
and managed to discover several
important locations the gel production
chamber on sub-level 3 creates glass
jars from the unidentified sandstone and
fills them with a slime that looks to
contain living eyes and teeth the
factory deliveries room is filled with a
huge number of crates and boxes which
seem to shift and change in number
between Foundation patrols the speaking
tube room on sub-level 11 contains a
grand Pulpit that acts as the Connecting
Point for the complex array of speaking
tubes running through the entire Cave
System the body parts of a deceased
female also appear to be wired into the
Machinery like spare parts and on
sub-level 12 they found the so-called
Catalyst room here they discovered a
huge complicated Clockwork and
steam-powered machine that appeared to
be broken and missing some parts most
horrifying of all though is the raised
platform in the center of the Catalyst
room on top of which is a metal hospital
bed a desiccated male corpse rests upon
the bed its chest punctured by large
syringes connected by tubes to some kind
of pumping machine the parts connecting
this pumping machine to the overall
apparatus of the room were missing
though leaving its purpose a mystery the
foundation assumed that fluids used to
be drawn out of this corpse to somehow
power the machine you may be starting to
worry that there doesn't seem to be any
answers here that this house is one big
mystery but lucky for you you're wrong
an old Journal was also discovered in
the Catalyst room and if what was
written inside is to be believed that we
may finally have some truth about who
created The House of the worm why it was
created and what horrible events
triggered its mysterious disappearance
and reappearance his true name has been
redacted by the foundation and special
efforts have been made to maintain
secrecy around the house seeing as it's
an anomaly of great interest to a cult
known as the Church of the broken God so
we'll just call the one who made this
place the inventor before any of this
the inventor was one of the many
Englishmen traumatized and almost killed
in the horrific trench battles of world
war one after a near-death experience
the inventor like many Geniuses and Mad
Men was plagued by surreal and
nightmarish Visions he saw a huge
creature that he referred to as the worm
a gigantic metal monstrosity with
dragon-like Jaws full of gnashing gears
that Rampage through Europe destroying
and devouring everything in its path
these apocalyptic Visions also presented
him with a solution vague blueprints for
a machine that might be the salvation of
him and others willing to take his new
gospel to her and escape from a world
that the inventor knew in his heart was
about to end he hired workstar laborers
from across the country to help him make
his Visions a reality and began a
massive secret construction project
beneath his isolated country manor house
for the inventor it was all a labor of
love he wanted to protect his wife son
and daughter from the terrible jaws of
the Worm but as the project stretched on
his wife began to suspect that he'd lost
his mind many of his workers however
felt just the opposite they became
infatuated by the inventor's sermons on
the nature of the worm and the coming
apocalypse they hoped to escape soon
enough they had become a bona fide cult
constructing the elaborate sub-levels
underneath the house in preparation for
the fast approaching day way of
Reckoning then came World War II the
inventor saw Hitler hungry for War as
one of the avatars of the worm finally
knowing that the time was right he
activated the machine and successfully
trapped the worm in the bowels of his
mechanized home however as the blitz
raged and London's bombing began the
inventor felt as though he hadn't
stopped anything he realized once and
for all that he was never meant to stop
the apocalypse only Escape it and by
throwing the final switch and setting
the machine he and his followers had
built into overdrive he did just that
this was the moment that the house of
the worm disappeared transporting the
inventor his family and his devoted
staff to a different world an empty gray
World devoid of War but also lacking all
the Comforts of regular life including
food things went downhill from there as
their supplies quickly began to run out
and the cult descended into cannibalism
in order to survive things weren't going
much better in the inventor's personal
life his wife fearing what would happen
to the family took her own life and the
life of his daughter though by this
point the inventor's mind was so
fractured that it's possible he may have
killed them himself either way it was
only the inventor and his son left and
more trouble was brewing Eudora one of
the staff trapped in the building with
the inventor and his cult started a
mutiny she claimed the worm spoke to her
from below and that their only path to
Salvation was pleasing the worm how
would they please it a sacrifice of
course they would give it the son of the
man who had trapped it the mutineers
took the inventors only remaining child
and descended into the lowest sub-levels
the inventor followed hoping to track
them down save his son and Salvage
something from this nightmare as he
ventured deeper battling the members of
eudora's new cult he found that they
were changing themselves becoming the
half-human cyborg creatures that the
Foundation would later discover the
inventor would find Eudora herself in
the speaking tube room her body still
living was wired into the machinery and
she had sacrificed his son to the worm
and a rage the inventor murdered Eudora
or whatever was left of her then heard a
familiar voice speaking out of a nearby
speaking tube it said I am what you have
made me I am then and I am now I am
choice and I am tyranny I am evil and I
am flesh I am Beauty and I am chaos I am
the worm the voice was his own in that
terrible moment the inventor realized
that the worm wasn't a giant
all-devouring monster it was him in
trying to protect his loved one from a
perceived apocalypse he brought them all
to their horrible demise he'd trapped
them with the monster he'd hope for them
all to escape from because no matter
what you build you can escape from who
you are grieve stricken and broken the
inventor descended into the Catalyst
room there was his son stuck with the
syringes drained of all life to fuel the
Mighty Machine his father had created in
his last moments the inventor decided to
do the only Noble thing he threw himself
into the machine destroying both it and
himself in the process the house was
transported back to our own reality but
the worm in a sense was no more but who
knows if the worm is really dead its
thoughts and poisonous intent still
lingers in the caverns and rattles
through the speaking pipes whatever
really happened the foundation is still
picking up the pieces today and who
knows what lurks in the parts still
hidden from our knowledge we've all
heard of the Led Zeppelin song Stairway
to Heaven a title that invokes the image
of a Stairway leading up to a land of
peace and Paradise but where else could
a Stairway lead to Dusty Attic full of
old photo albums to the upper level of a
mall where the movie theater and frozen
yogurt shop are neatly situated perhaps
it leads to a rooftop with a beautiful
view or maybe just maybe a staircase
could lead you to
scp-2427
scp-2427 appropriately nicknamed a thing
full of stuff is an extra dimensional
area filled with a variety of unusual
and anomalous objects
scp-2427 can be accessed by way of a
broken Stone staircase located in rural
Ohio according to local Legend carrying
a sprig of Hemlock up the broken stairs
will allow a person to emerge into a
mysterious grass clearing that appears
to be in a forest somewhere in the
United States no matter what time a
person ascends the staircase the solar
time in the clearing will always be 2PM
you know how people say It's Five
O'Clock Somewhere well it's two o'clock
somewhere too and that somewhere is here
the pocket Dimension that is
scp-2427 is thought to have been a
holding area for weapons prisoners and
artifacts belonging to an ancient cult
known as the Brazen heart little is
known about this relatively obscure cult
other than the fact that they worship
the Demonic entity moloch a known
Enthusiast of violent human sacrifice
and were previously thought to have been
eradicated during the Spanish
Inquisition the existence of scp-2427
suggests that they are very much not
eradicated and are still active they
refer to these holding areas as addicts
and though no confirmed members of the
Brazen heart have been contacted it is
considered possible that there are at
least a handful of other addicts hidden
around the world the foundation has
identified seven anomalous objects
inside of
scp-2427 so far each strange in its own
beautiful though often terrible way like
snowflakes if they were capable of
killing or maiming you the first object
in
scp-2427 AKA
scp-2427-1 is a seemingly normal fire
hydrant however if you think there's
anything normal about the items found
here then you haven't been paying
attention the hydrant is made out of
lead and when opened it expels high
levels of ionized radiation no specific
measurements of the radiation have been
taken yet but it is definitely hazardous
to human health one unfortunate member
of d-class personnel has proven that it
is a high enough level to melt human
flesh sorry about your face Dave the
hydrant is currently contained within an
electrified perimeter and is not to be
opened under any circumstances to
prevent any further flesh melting the
last thing we need is another Dave
incident the second object contained
with an scp-2427 or
scp-2427-2 is not actually an object at
all it's a bill building only on number
two and we're already throwing
curveballs at you trust no one surprises
lurk around every corner this particular
building resembles a large multi-storied
sanitarium built in the 1860s though it
is clear from the outside that the
building has or should have multiple
Stories the inside is a different matter
past the building's front doors is a
non-euclidean space consisting of a
single floor and three sparsely
decorated rooms with one Central foyer
the first room is the holding place for
scp-2427-3 the second contains
scp-2427-4 and the third room contains
nothing except scattered religious
documents bottled water and a selection
of canned food no unauthorized staff are
permitted to enter the building in order
to minimize complications or potential
employee casualties the first two
anomalies on this list are hardly even
strange by a CP foundation's standards
sure the hydrant can melt your race and
the building defies the laws of physics
and space but that's just a regular
Tuesday around these parts
been there seen that what else you got
well
scp-2427-3 is where things really get
strange if you're wandering through the
bowels of
scp-2427-2 when you make a wrong turn
into the first room you will find
yourself face to face with a startling
sight this entity is a combination of
electronic circuitry a cow's digestive
tract the hairless head of a human man a
hat rack several lengths of garden hose
and an unidentified crystalline
structure this creature is
extraordinarily fast and strong
exhibiting carnivorous tendencies in a
very strong point of view on the world
around it lucky for us it is capable of
speech and is able to tell us just what
it thinks though this monstrosity
doesn't have much of a right to pass
judgment on anyone cow intestine body
and all it has expressed a violent
hatred of all life that it considers
impure anyone who encounters
scp-2427-3 experiences an overwhelming
desire to submit themselves for judgment
allowing the creature to determine their
purity there is a rumor that if one is
judged to be pure they will have a wish
granted if they are deemed impure
however they will be devoured alive if
you're tempted to introduce yourself to
the creature your odds are not
especially great the creature has not
encountered a single pure being yet in
order to protect the foundation staff
working in its vicinity the entrance to
scp-2427-3's room has been sealed off
with a reinforced steel door and the
windows have been paved over with
concrete armed guards are watching the
entrance at all times the creature must
be fed one live goat per day in order to
keep its appetite satiated the
foundation's goat budget is through the
roof these days but it's worth it to
keep the thing contained better to spend
money on goats now and not spend money
on cannibalized Personnel later
scp-2427-4 consists not of an object
located within a room but the room
itself the room which contains no
furniture and a linoleum floor has a
peculiar effect on the human psyche once
a person steps foot into the room they
lose Consciousness for five minutes
during this time they will speak freely
listing off a variety of negative
qualities about themselves once they
wake up they have no memory of entering
the state or anything that they said
during it it's cheaper than therapy
right but it's also much weirder and
less effective so you get what you pay
for in the end a member of d-class
personnel who was observed inside of the
room wax poetic about his personal
failings beginning his monologue with my
soul is a den of spiders and ending it
with oh here once I awaken hesitate not
to feed my flesh and my soul to the
judge Beast somebody give this guy a hug
because the room seems to have no
adverse effects on human test subjects
except for causing everyone who hears
their monologue a bit of discomfort
there are no containment procedures in
effect for it at this time we've had
rooms fire hydrants and horrible meat
robot hybrids and now you can't even
trust the clouds in the sky
scp-2427-5 is a seemingly innocent Cloud
hovering stationary over the building
when looked at by a human for more than
three seconds the cloud will eject a
ball of solid lead towards the person at
a supersonic speed that's right folks
This Cloud can and will shoot you it
hates being observed but it also hates
when you try to leave the perimeter it
will attack any person attempting to
leave by firing the same lead ball at
them so far 14 Personnel have been
killed by this highly aggressive cloud
and some people still think
thunderstorms and hail are the worst
things clouds have to offer so naive as
it is a literal Cloud there is no way to
contain it so no people in the vicinity
of the cloud are permitted to look at it
for more than three seconds at a time
scp-2427-6 is a series of 18 small trees
spread throughout the instance of
scp-2427 above ground the trees looked
normal though their species has proven
surprisingly difficult to determine from
an external perspective they are simply
ordinary trees however radar analysis
revealed that the roots of these trees
are deeply strange instead of the usual
twisting tree roots the ground below
these trees contains a mass in the shape
of a human body much to the disgust of
the observing researchers these humanoid
masses occasionally twitch and move as
if alive the trees themselves appear to
be growing from the crotch area of each
humanoid figure how's that for
Morningwood I know I get it bad joke
this Arrangement between tree and person
seems to be some kind of punishment as
each tree is marked with a plaque
reading the letters suffer what they
must and it is beautiful until it can be
certain that the condition of these
human Roots is not contagious these
trees are to be treated as potential
biohazards and isolated in individual
containers the final object in
scp-2427 currently categorized by the
foundation is
scp-2427-7
scp-2427-7 is a pile of ashes and Wood
located just behind a posted sign that
reads the Liar's cradle extensive
testing has been established that the
Liar's cradle was almost certainly used
as a torture device and interrogations
performed by the Brazen heart a person
standing within the boundaries of the
Cradle which encompasses the
aforementioned circle of wood and Ashes
is unable to lie without suffering the
consequences namely they will be set on
fire the nature of how exactly the
Liar's cradle works is not certain and
more research needs to be done on it
however this much is known for sure it
contains no sentient intelligence it is
not aware of what it is doing it does
not kill its victims rather it keeps
them miraculously alive as it sets them
on fire prolonging their Agony and
allowing their interrogators to get the
truth out of them a series of
experiments reveal that it only emulates
a person who is knowingly lying d-class
Personnel give demonstrably false
information to repeat in the Cradle
without knowledge of its falsehood were
not set on fire however when those same
d-class Personnel knowingly lied in the
boundaries they immediately were set
Ablaze it is almost certain that the
Brazen heart cult used the Cradle as a
method of interrogating presumed Liars
in their midst further investigation
will likely reveal human remains beneath
the Cradle itself though this is just a
hypothesis currently but come on there
has to be some bones somewhere beneath
something as ominous says the Liar's
cradle though they have only identified
seven anomalies inside
scp-2427 at the moment there are plenty
more lurking in there waiting to be
discovered in the foyer of
scp-2427-2 the foundation discovered an
extremely ominous list of items clearly
belonging to members of The Cult of the
Brazen heart this list included some
familiar items such as Pilgrim
Provisions also known as the canned
beans and soup found in
scp-2427-2 a level 3 Purity Proctor a
purge engine disguised as a fire hydrant
and the Liar's cradle however it also
contained many things that have not yet
been discovered such as one slaughtering
perseverance 27 pyre children three
ascended cultivars seven Supreme
angelics Nine Dragons and the Brazen
heart itself Dr Gordon McElroy site
director of area 2427 put out a memo to
all level 4 and hire staff assigned to
the area after the discovery of this
list understandably he was most
concerned about the Supreme angelics and
the dragons particularly the latter the
cult has most Cults are is fond of
deliberately obscure language but you
don't want to rule out the possibility
they've got a fire-breathing lizard or
two stashed away in the meantime as the
foundation is working to better
understand the contents of
scp-2427 the area has been sealed off to
the public a 500 meter perimeter has
been established around its entrance and
a fake private Country Club has been set
up as a front it's only a matter of time
before the rest of the anomalies on the
list are discovered and this thing full
of stuff gets even Fuller of even more
stuff let's just hope none of it ever
gets out because if there are more of
these addicts out there who knows what
else the Brazen heart is hiding their
little cult may not be as a distinct as
we thought you're right in the middle of
one of the hottest Summers on record the
days are filled with bright scorching
sun and Searing heat and you've been
laying around with your air conditioning
on full blast just to try and cool
yourself off sadly it's not really
working and the heat is becoming way too
much but then you remember there's this
married couple that lives near you with
no kids and they happen to have a
swimming pool in their yard normally
they keep to themselves they'd never let
you use their pool but they've gone out
of town for a few days besides the heat
is killing you you're sure that the
neighbors wouldn't mind if you just took
a quick dip as long as you clean up
after yourself they probably wouldn't
even notice you were even there
cautiously you make your way to their
house it's an unremarkable Place similar
to most of the other houses in this
suburb of New Mexico after checking that
there's nobody else around you climb the
two meter high Cinder block wall that
stands around the back Garden as you
drop to your feet sweaty and panting
from the unrelenting summer heat you see
it the pool your salvation water never
looks so appealing immediately you step
Barefoot across the Sun scorched tiles
and sit on the edge legs and the water
it's cool and refreshing perfect for a
day is hot as today you're already
changed in wearing your swim trunks so
it doesn't take long for you to paddle
out to the middle of the pool letting
that chilled clean water cool you off as
you're taking a dip you notice the
pool's Jets turning on automatically
it's a little bit odd but you shrug it
off that couple clearly shelled out for
a pool with a lot of fancy bells and
whistles but extra features aren't why
you're here you came because if you
didn't then you could have melted under
all that sunlight floating on the
surface of the water you relax with your
arms behind your head and close your
eyes you don't have time to realize that
coming here was a mistake instead you
start to feel relaxed so calm so
tranquil you're one with the water
around you now it's almost as though you
could just disappear so you do the
police never find any trace of you
everyone else simply writes it off as a
random disappearance there's not even so
much as a scrap of your body left in the
pool just the clear clean water why
because the swimming pool you decided to
take a cooling dip in wasn't an ordinary
pool it was
scp-242 but don't worry you won't be the
last to make that costly mistake what
you didn't know is that the married
couple who live in that house are
secretly a pair of SCP Foundation
doctors the house isn't even theirs the
foundation procured it after the former
owner a retired out-of-state landlord
strangely vanished he had been
struggling to find anyone to rent the
place so he eventually decided to give
up on the property game and move in
there himself after three days he was
never seen again now that house has only
one rule that must be followed above all
else do not swim in the pool
scp-242 is at least to the untrained eye
just an average swimming pool a decent 9
meters in length four and a half wide
and it holds around 53 000 liters of
sterile pool water like we mentioned
before it's even got some Nifty features
like water jets a dual waterfall and a
built-in vacuum unit for sucking out any
impurities and we mean any impurities
you see scp-242 does go by another name
the self-cleaning pool and while that
might not sound as foreboding or
dramatic as the Scarlet king or the
wendigo skull or the horrifying nasty
dude of ultimate Badness okay we made
that last one up we can assure you that
you don't ever want to suffer the fate
of taking a swim in this pool there was
an incident a while ago recorded by the
foundation through a secret hidden
camera the house where scp-242 can be
found had been left vacant for a time
and once again some opportunists decided
to take advantage of the empty swimming
pool this time it was a couple a man and
a woman in their early 20s they climbed
up the back wall undressed and even
stole a couple of plastic inflatable
rafts from a shed in The house's
backyard the water jets switched
themselves on startling the girl but her
boyfriend told her not to worry the
filter to clean the pool was probably
just on an automatic timer right surely
it wouldn't have been anything to worry
about after swimming together for around
24 minutes the couple both agreed that
the water felt warm tingly even both of
them climbed onto their rafts eventually
falling asleep while still holding each
other's hands but almost half an hour
after the Jets had started something
caused the two rafts to burst the couple
awoke startled by the loud pop of the
splitting Inflatables and being plunged
back into the water the pool around them
immediately began frothing violently and
deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed
in fear and Agony both of them tried to
desperately swim to the edge hoping to
leave the pool and get to safety but
unfortunately that plan didn't work
before they could reach the edge the man
and the woman were Pulled Under the
surface of the Raging Water their limbs
thrashing as they still tried in vain to
escape eventually they vanished under
the Crimson bloody water the frothing
slowly began to calm and the red in the
pool dissipated once again becoming
clearer after 48 seconds the couple were
never seen again and a cover story was
leaked to the Press by the SCP
Foundation two weeks after they went
missing according to them the pair had a
lope together somewhere in Mexico if
only that sounds a lot nice than what
actually happened to them so this
swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties that much is obvious but what
exactly are those properties how exactly
does scp-242 work is it an
interdimensional Gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if
they spend too long swimming in it or is
the swimming pool itself a sentient
carnivorous creature that lures humans
in only to devour them maybe the water
is teeming with invisible flesh-eating
piranhas that can strip the meat from
the bone in a matter of seconds well
good guesses all around but actually
it's none of these it's unclear what
causes the pool's anomalous effects it
could be a property that is completely
unique to the water contained in scp-242
or maybe it's down to the exact shape
and measurements of the pool itself it
could even be a combination of both but
whatever the cause the result is always
the same when any object substance or
even living organism is placed in
scp-242 it will be entirely Rewritten on
a molecular level the genetic anatomic
structure will fall apart and the
subject will be transmuted into sterile
water in fact not just clean water but
water that remains sterile even when
removed from the pool if you took a cup
of scp-242's water and mixed something
like food coloring into it the food
coloring would not be absorbed into the
water instead staying as one
non-missable bubble this process doesn't
happen instantly though it can vary
depending on how contaminated or complex
the substance placed in scp-242 is for
example water sampled from a nearby
River was sterilized and purified by the
pool in about seven minutes a sample of
stagnant pond water riddled with various
diseases and germs took 11 minutes
longer what about 50 000 liters of coal
tar well that one took a little longer
12 long days to be exact but was still
still turned into pure sterile water and
as for a living human being maybe ask
that couple that took a dip in the
self-cleaning pool the foundation is
naturally fascinated with the pool and
after extensive examination they have
determined that scp-242 doesn't seem to
have been intentionally designed for the
specific anomalous function it performs
the components of scp-242 beyond the
pool itself the filter the vacuum the
pipes none of these parts nor anything
about the swimming pool's design appear
to be responsible for disintegrating
matter until only water remains you
might have noticed that in the case of
the ill-fated couple who took a swim in
scp-242 the water jets and waterfall
features switched themselves on
automatically before the pair's Grim
demise somehow these features are able
to activate without the need for
electricity as disconnecting the pool
from a power source will not stop the
Jets and waterfall from coming on once a
non-water substance is placed into
scp-242 the same goes for the pool
vacuum which apparently cannot be jammed
or malfunction even when the bottom of
the pool is a wash with viscous liquids
like that coal tar the vacuum will
continue to operate as normal scrubbing
away at the floor of scp-242 the one
part of the self-cleaning pool that
doesn't work as you would expect is the
water filtration system there is never
any water being cycled into the pool nor
out of it as a matter of fact the pipes
connecting to the filtration system have
all been removed then again who needs a
filtration system when your backyard
swimming pool can just spontaneously
reduce anything to clean water but that
raises another frightening thought
everything that the pool has ever taken
and converted is still in there animals
objects people just swimming around you
perhaps if they could still think they'd
scream and shout and tell you to get
away to run while you still can but the
second your skin touches the water
you're destined to be with them forever
and ever and ever it's enough to send a
liquid chill down your spine okay so if
it's not the actual physical pull that
causes these anomalous effects that must
mean it's something in the water right
perhaps a microscopic flesh devouring
microbe or some ancient curse that was
placed on the water before it was used
to fill up the pool surely if you took a
cup of water out of scp-242 it would
still break down structures on a
molecular level leaving only more
sterile water while the researchers
working at the SCP Foundation thought
much of the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact
properties of
scp-242's water one test involves
submerging two d-class test subjects
each wearing an atmospheric dive suit
into scp-242 the goal was to determine
if it was safe to consume the water from
scp-242 while both inside and outside of
the pool test subject a was lowered into
the water and instructed to drink from a
metal straw by their mouth the eyepieces
of their goggles were blacked out so
they couldn't see what they were
drinking from subject B filled a barrel
with the same water from scp-242 and
then was made to put on an atmospheric
dive suit but instructed to stay out of
the pool test subject a was told to
drink directly from the pool remarking
that the water was warm and had a bit of
a noticeable chemical aftertaste but was
otherwise normal then test subject B
drank some of the same water from the
barrel apparently it was cool and tasted
of well nothing just like water usually
does after a moment more of drink
subject a began belching finding that
they had uncontrollable gas the water
had begun to feel warmer stinging the
subject's mouth while for subject B the
water from the barrel stayed cool and
refreshing the foundation doctors
overseeing the experiment instructed
test subject day to keep drinking which
they did until it felt even hotter to
The Taste one of the d-class's fillings
even fell out and eventually the
structural Integrity of subject A's dive
suit failed presumably disintegrated by
the water from scp-242 after a few
muffled screams and gurgling noises test
subject a wasn't heard from again and we
can all probably guess why as for
subject B they kept drinking from the
barrel suffering no adverse effects even
after 17 long hours there were no
noticeable psychological or physical
changes even their urine showed no
traces of abnormality the water from
scp-242 left in the barrel evaporated as
normal leaving behind no residue or any
indicator as to why taking the water out
of the pool made it safer to drink than
the same water in the pool perhaps the
moral of the story is to just be careful
where you choose to take a swim
otherwise it could be your last
you're on a road trip the kind that
stretches over days on end and you need
to make multiple stops along the way to
refuel the car and yourself the last
time you remember stopping to get more
gas and a bite to eat was back in
Wyoming and now you're in the heart of
Montana thankfully like an oasis in the
desert you see the town of Clearwater
off in the distance it's a vibrant
welcoming little place a perfect slice
of classic small town Americana you took
a similar trip last year and vaguely
remember stopping at Clearwater that
time too and you're glad to be back in
particular you remember the old Prairie
Diner a folksy little place with the
most delicious Huckleberry pie you ever
tasted perhaps it's about time for you
to give it another try you fill up your
tank and stop at the diner the food
tastes just as good as you remember but
one thing is off the entire staff seems
to have changed it is the exact same
Diner you ate at a year ago no doubt
about that but it looks like everyone
from from the weight staff to the
cashier to the cooks have all been
replaced you try your best not to think
about it after all businesses are
allowed to replace their staff but the
longer you sit in the diner the more
uncomfortable the feelings become you
need to ask someone just to push away
the fears that you're not going crazy
when the waiter passes by you compliment
the food and mention you ate here last
year too you asked the unfamiliar waiter
if they had worked here back then they
confirmed that yes they've always worked
here and so has everybody else the diner
is a family business you leave town not
too long after that feeling vaguely
unsettled and as a voice on the radio
warns about the incoming rain you tell
yourself that you never want to return
to the town of Clearwater Montana as you
leave the memory of the Town seems to
fade from your mind in real time but
little do you know the people of
Clearwater will never be able to leave
ever it's because something horrifying
will happen in Clearwater every single
year and that thing is known to the SCP
Foundation as
scp-3300 this annual anomalous event is
Clearwater's own local curse always
occurring around mid-june while many of
the mechanics of this event still elude
the foundation's understanding the
outcome is well documented every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a
person who didn't previously exist while
some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts every person
involved will simply be a whole new
person with no memories of the change or
who they once were the process known as
scp-3300 lasts between 6 and 18 days and
once the process has begun it's
impossible for any Outsiders to
intervene it begins with rain a light
dreary drizzle at first but each day the
rain gets worse soon it's a storm and
then a Maelstrom flooding hurricanes
tornadoes all centered around Clearwater
but cutting off neatly just beyond it
what happens in Clearwater remains in
Clear Water and when the process has
concluded and The Sun Shines once more
everybody has been changed whenever the
foundation has tried to send Personnel
or equipment into clear water during
scp-3300 one of two things has happened
in the more favorable scenarios those
attempting to enter Clearwater have
simply appeared on the other side of the
city limits in the less positive
instances personnel and Equipment have
been lost forever within there is no
stopping or even understanding scp-3300
according to Foundation records
Clearwater has been around at least as
long as the foundation itself perhaps
even longer Clearwater has been able to
undergo its yearling nightmare without
intrusion due to a unique Cognito
hazardous effect which creates a kind of
mental block around memories of the town
for Outsiders you won't forget clear
water per se but you will find it
increasingly hard to focus on like
something you can only ever see out of
the corner of your eye there is no
saving the people of clear water the
horror will play out again and again and
again the foundation is no firsthand
knowledge of what happens in Clear Water
during those horrifying 18 days but one
account they have hints at a terrifying
possibility during an Excursion into
Clear Water the foundation managed to
collect a diary belonging to a woman
named Margaret Lane to the best of our
knowledge Margaret Lane no longer exists
but if the contents of her diary aren't
to be believed then what goes on in
Clearwater during scp-3300 is far worse
than we ever imagined Margaret first
started her diary not long before
scp-3300's 1995 iteration began she was
in the middle of a tumultuous time in
her life freshly clean from alcohol and
drug addiction forced to live with her
antagonistic mother and having peculiar
and distressing dreams in the first
Dream Margaret recorded she was someone
else a woman living in a small Hut
perhaps a century ago or more it was
plague time she was looking down upon
her daughter bedridden her skin covered
in painful looking red blotches her
husband was already dead that's when
another man enters a healthy man he
tells her that he's found their
salvation and then the dream ended
Margaret woke up to a gray dreary day
there were clouds on the horizon the
rain was coming it drizzled for the next
few days before getting more intense as
one would expect from an scp-3300 cycle
of course nothing seemed out of place to
Margaret life carried on she continued
to stay clean resisting the offers of
her old dealer though her relationship
with her mother remained Frosty the rain
started to get worse as voices on the
radio insisted that conditions would
continue to become more severe over the
next few days they tried their best to
maintain normality Margaret invited some
friend Jared Sam Mike and Isabelle to
come over and play D D at her place that
was when all hell broke loose while the
group role played there was a furious
banging at the door like whoever was
knocking was trying to bash the door
down when Margaret's mom opened the door
to investigate the commotion she saw
that an entire family was standing there
a father a mother and two young children
the father immediately began furiously
asking why all these strangers were in
his house when Margaret's mother tried
to tell him that this wasn't his house
he became increasingly agitated and
walked straight into the home Margaret's
friends attempted to subdue him but he
threw them off displaying a supernatural
strength Margaret's mom ran in with a
golf club and struck the mysterious man
in the chest there was a nasty Splat but
he didn't seem to react the golf club
was just embedded in his chest having
broken the skin and sunken in but there
was no blood just dripping Lauder the
father then pulled the golf club out of
his chest and began beating Margaret's
mother to death with it all while
repeating my house again and again while
his wife and children watched with broad
Sunny Smiles in the rain somehow
Margaret knew that her mother was beyond
saving and that there was no way of
defeating these things in a physical
confrontation all they could do was run
out to Jared's van with the rest of the
group and hightail it to the police
station but when they arrived at the
station the doors were barred and it
appeared empty as the torrential rain
hammered down from above there was
nothing left to do but drive out of town
and try to escape whatever Madness was
going on here but that was easier said
than done they drove for what seemed
like hours on end as the rain and the
howling wind persisted Jared had been
injured during the fight with the
strange family and his health
deteriorated further as the drive
stretched on they should have left the
town of Clearwater a long time ago but
it seemed like they were nowhere it
wasn't long before Jared was lying going
dead in the back of the van and now
there are only four of them left they
kept driving afraid grieving hungry and
tired and Margaret took the opportunity
to sleep it was no time to rest but she
was so exhausted that she had no choice
Margaret had a continuation of her
earlier dream the different her the
dream her was laying the plague-ridden
body of her daughter in the river but
she wasn't the only one all the Villages
of her settlement were placing the
bodies of their dead in the river as the
water washed around them and through
them the bodies became one with the
water and then they became the water the
water was everything when Margaret awoke
it was to the horrifying sounds of
bubbling and boiling that's when she saw
that Jared's body was dissolving now not
dissolving evaporating it was bubbling
and convulsing like it was made of water
until the entire thing burst into a
Cascade of hot steam after that Ma
Margaret and the others left the vehicle
and refused to get back inside nothing
was making sense it was like something
out of a nightmare as they walked the
rain hammered down upon them they
couldn't have been walking for more than
a mile when they crashed into something
it was a sign welcome to Clear Water it
was like that the town itself had drawn
them back Mike refused to return to the
town of his own free will and began
walking in the other direction moments
later he was walking back towards them
in silence though he never intended to
scp-3300 had distorted his path and
brought him back it was clear that Mike
was shaken to the core by the experience
but they had to press on they would head
to the grocery store for food and then
to a sporting goods store where they
could hopefully grab some guns to fight
the violent altered people who'd somehow
appeared with the rain but things didn't
go to plan or what little plan there
even was Mike shot himself on the first
night at Dirk's Sporting Goods leaving
only Margaret Sam and Isabelle alive
perhaps one of the most terrifying
details of Mike's death was the fact he
didn't even bleed instead the gaping
exit wound in the back of his head was
just full of water water was all that
seemed to be left of them Sam seemingly
driven to the Edge by the sight of
Mike's death grabbed a hunting knife to
perform an experiment she'd cut it into
her own skin and was horrified to see
only water dripping out they'd all been
changed and they didn't know why that's
when the survivors noticed something
else there were people standing outside
in the rain hundreds of them not a
single one they could recognize all new
people waiting Sam said only one word
outside before walking out of the
hunting goods store and disappearing
into the crowd and the rain never to be
seen Again Margaret Muse that perhaps in
the end she had the right idea to be
taken killed or raced or changed would
be inevitable in the final entry in
Margaret's diary dreams blend with
reality as her mind finally gives out
from the terror she realizes in her
final moments that there is no way out
there is no Escape there is only water
water is eternal the rain is eternal all
will be changed and given the fact that
no trace of Margaret was ever found
saved for her diary all her fears turned
out to be right she was taken and
replaced by scp-3300 just as will
inevitably happen to all the current
citizens of Clearwater the next time
scp-3300 rolls around it will be as
inevitable and as indifferent to those
it affects as tomorrow's sunrise you
cannot change the rain but believe us in
Clearwater Montana the rain can change
you there's a monster under my bed
almost every parent has heard their kids
make the claim and it's usually nothing
more than some unusual Shadows or at
worst a household pest scurrying around
parents usually tell their child to go
back to sleep or maybe try to dispel
their fears by shining a light under the
bed it's a childhood ride of Passage and
one that usually passes soon enough but
for one young woman in Missouri the
monster under her bed was very real and
very dangerous
scp-3887-a doesn't seem like she belongs
in a containment facility she's a 24
year old woman who lived a quiet life in
her hometown until things went horribly
wrong she doesn't appear to possess any
special abilities and the foundation is
able to contain her without any
difficulty but wherever she goes death
and destruction follow it's not her
doing but there is something out there
that will not stand to see her hurt in
any way her personal monster under the
bed is very protective something another
young woman found out the hard way in
incident
3887-8-1 occurred in 2014 when the young
woman was attending a party with her
girlfriend her partner was berating and
humiliating her in front of the guests
which was apparently not a rare
occurrence in their relationship
suddenly something manifested under a
nearby table and before she could react
her girlfriend was brutally mauled by
the unknown creature her limbs were
completely severed from her body and she
died at the scene an undercover a CP
agent who was implanted within the local
authorities made their way to the scene
as soon as possible and found
scp-3887-a in a State of Shock and who
could blame her after the encounter she
just had with what would become to be
known as
scp-3887-b while
3887-a is a normal human with no unusual
abilities or characteristics
3887-b is anything but Foundation
scientists have described it as a
humanoid entity standing over seven feet
tall its skin is greenish gray and it
has two long sharp horns on its head its
head and neck are covered in thick black
hair and its eyes are a striking yellow
color its mouth is full of sharp fangs
similar to that of a shark and its
elongated arms allow it to move on all
fours it has a long hairless tail that
resembles a rats and possesses both male
and female reproductive organs no one
knows where it came from but they do
have an idea why it's sticking around
scp-3887-b seems to be bonded to
scp-3887-a and can appear in any
darkened area within a 5 meter radius
around her while its favorite location
is under
3887-a's bed which has since been
brought to the facility it appears to be
able to teleport wherever she is just as
it did during the party where it made
its presence brutally clear it has odd
eating patterns and is able to gain
nourishment from practically any object
whether resembles what we would consider
food or not its favorite treats for
example
scp-3887-a's socks but it does have one
weakness that has been useful in
containing it it can't stand the light
and it doesn't just hate it when
scp-3887-b is exposed to Bright Light it
develops blisters and wounds and fleas
to the nearest dark area SCP Foundation
scientists are at a loss to explain
exactly what this creature is though and
scp-3887-b seems to be a chimera of
multiple animals with multiple types of
DNA it possesses DNA similar to humans
but also from a type of oryx with
similar horns as well as a rat with the
same type of tail as well as a common
cane toad and there's even some DNA that
doesn't resemble any creature in nature
studying it further has been trickier
though because it seems to have the
effect of disrupting any electronic
recording devices near it causing
lasting damage if it's in proximity to
them for too long there has been one
good bit of news for SCP scientists
though because while it has shown that
it can be extremely violent it has not
attacked Foundation officials not yet at
least its good behavior may not have
anything to do with how it personally
feels about Foundation staff though and
is instead all thanks to
scp-3887-a
3887-a has been completely Cooperative
since she was taken into custody by the
foundation she doesn't perceive them as
a threat and so far it seems like
scp-3887-b is following her lead it has
a strong emotional connection to the
young woman and when they're alone they
show affectionate Behavior towards each
other while the creature does not seem
to like the foundation it doesn't seem
like it wants to become hostile until
the foundation gives it a reason to when
3887-a was interviewed following the
tragic incident by undercover Foundation
agent Bellamy she was panicked and
terrified she admitted that her partner
often treated her badly and believed
that the creature was trying to protect
her she admitted that she had seen the
creature before she even had a name for
it she called her Brenda
3887-shay thought she was crazy now
there was proof though she was not
Imagining the monster under her bed
describing Grenda as her Boogeyman the
young woman talked about how she had
known the creature since she was a child
she grew up in an old house in the
country that was full of strange sounds
that made it sound like something was in
her room with her and sometimes she
would even catch a glimpse of what she
thought was a monster under her bed
watching her she tried telling her
parents what they thought she was making
the whole thing
and even she was forced to wonder if she
was hallucinating or had somehow
imagined the whole thing but then when
she was a teenager all of her doubts
were put to bed one night
3887-8's parents were loudly fighting a
sadly not rare occurrence in their
household and she locked herself in her
room to get away from them as she hid
Grenda emerged from under her bed for
the first time and talked with her and
she isn't the only one that Grenda is
willing to speak with she's also sat
down for her own interviews with
Foundation researchers well the
researchers sat down while Grenda
remained under the bed Foundation
researcher Dr Tanner interviewed Grenda
who was cordial but guarded and remained
deeply protective of the girl under her
protection she expressed feeling guilty
for getting
3887-a in trouble but Dr Tanner assured
her that 3887-a was not being punished
and was being being kept at the
foundation for her own safety he offered
that they could keep Grenda safe as well
but she responded that as long as
3887-8 remains safe then she would be as
well she explained that her kind fed on
the anxiety of children which was why
they lurked under their beds she was
apparently only supposed to remain with
this girl until she was 10 or so but
became attached and decided to stay with
her which was against the rules of her
people and as a result she had been
exiled from her home at this point
Grenda offered to show herself to the
researcher and began to emerge from
under the bed unfortunately as has
become standard when attempting to
document
scp-3887-b all of the recording
equipment malfunctioned and was unable
to record grenda's appearance the
foundation continued to have questions
about this pair and their strange
relationship and interviewed
scp-3887-a again This Time by a doctor
Garden
3887-8 told Dr Garden that she had been
sleeping well and had been spending lots
of time talking to the entity under her
bed that led Dr Garden to bring up a
theory about how
scp-3887-b had come to exist the young
woman speculated that Grenda may have
been created from her fears one of her
first memories of being scared was when
she went to an aquarium and a massive
bull shark came close to the glass where
barred its rows and rows of shark teeth
the exact same kind of teeth that Grenda
possessed in fact all the traits grende
exhibited like a rat tail seemed to
connect to Childhood fears that she had
experienced
3887-a always felt alone as a little
girl and she believed that she might
have manifested Grenda as a companion
who was there exactly when she needed
her to be this raised the question of
whether
scp-3887-b really was the unknown
natural entity or if
scp-3887-a is the source of the entities
existence the next interview with
scp-3887-b would raise even more
questions when Dr Garden went to
interview
scp-3887-b it was clear that the entity
was agitated Grenda became hostile as
soon as Dr Garden entered the room
saying she was hungry and didn't want to
answer questions when Dr Garden said
that 3887-a had provided it with socks
The Entity reacted with anger the socks
were just a snack to live it needed fear
3887-b fed off human emotions
specifically paranoia and anxiety
scp-3887-a used to be full of them but
now she was unusually calm in the
facility and it was having a bad effect
on her companion when Dr Garden promised
to talk to supervisors the creature
became more agitated and and reached out
from under the bed grabbing Dr garden
and pulling her under the bed no one
knew what would happen to Dr Garden
under the bed and
scp-3887-a was quickly summoned to try
to calm her companion down but when she
called for Grenda there was no response
it was feared that Dr Garden had been
lost to the area under the bed that no
one can access but then 13 minutes later
the doctor suddenly emerged from under
the bed she was bruised soaking wet and
missing articles including shoes socks
and her glasses later interviews with Dr
Garden would give the best picture yet
of where
scp-3887-b comes from Dr Garden
described being pulled under the bed
which then LED somewhere else entirely
she fell for 15 seconds still being held
by
scp-3887-b but when she landed she was
alone in a large cave made of black rock
with purple gems in the walls the cave
contained and a waterfall a lake and
what looked like
scp-3887's secret home it was filled
with pictures of the girl she was bonded
to a violin some stuffed animals and
large piles of the girl's socks
scp-3887-b was there in the cave with
her too watching her she would catch
glimpses of the creature her white fangs
and her yellow eyes she was terrified
and ran screaming trying to find any way
out of there as the creature pursued her
she couldn't evade her forever though
and eventually Grenda grabbed Dr Garden
she was lifted into the air as Grenda
bared her shark-like teeth but instead
of eating her the creature instead took
off the doctor's socks and thanked her
before somehow sending her back up into
the darkness she then found herself back
under the bed surrounded by worried SCP
Personnel since then
scp-3887-b has not brought anyone else
into its home it seems feeding on Dr
Garden's fear was enough for the time
being and the situation has remained
stable since the SCP Foundation has been
able to develop relatively simple
containment procedures for the two
entities that make up
scp-3887 as neither is currently hostile
the two are contained within a standard
humanoid containment cell with the bed
at the center
scp-3887-a is given standard amenities a
healthy diet including a vitamin for
some minor health issues and our own
control over the lights in the cell she
has requested and been given a gaming
system for entertainment and up-to-date
entertainment media but was denied
access to the internet a pet cat and
access to the on-site Recreation areas
due to the risk of
scp-3887-b getting loose the facility
does have plans in place in case Grenda
decides to become hostile again though
while
scp-3887-a normally maintains control of
the lights in her cell the foundation
has a Fail-Safe installed so they can
turn them up at any time since
scp-3887-b reacts negatively to Bright
Light the lights can be used as a
security system to send her retreating
back under the bed until she can be
pacified through other measures while
neither of the scp-3887 entities appears
to be seeking to escape it is impossible
to predict where and how
3887-b would act if 3887-a was free for
mercel again and whether she would
attempt to harm those she perceives as a
threat to
3887-a as she did in the past so for now
the foundation is focused on keeping
both of them pacified which in the case
of
3887-b means a healthy supply of socks
but there's one other lingering question
the foundation hasn't solved
scp-3887-b referenced being exiled from
its kin for breaking the rules and was
confined line to a cave that means there
might be others like Grenda out there
and they may be more aggressive and less
scrupulous than she is while no other
specimens have been found the SCP
Foundation will be keeping a careful eye
on any reports of monsters lurking under
children's beds they might just be
telling the truth lots of people believe
in the possibility of past lives the
notion that the life we are currently
living is not our first before you were
the person you are now sitting at home
and watching this video maybe you were a
medieval King a Renaissance painter or
an ancient Spartan warrior past life
regression is a controversial practice
that allows people to look back at their
supposed past lives Looking Through The
Eyes of someone in another lifetime it
is a nice idea and there's something
exciting about the possibility of
reliving the experiences of a person
from the past and wouldn't you know it
the SCP Foundation just so happened to
discover an artifact that allows a
person to experience another person's
memories it is not past life regression
and you have no control over whose life
you're peeking into but it allows you to
look at the world through their eyes
however when you look through someone
else's eyes there's always the
possibility that you will see something
you didn't want to something troubling
frightening even traumatic or worse so
you may not want to subject yourself to
scp-1123 or as it has been ominously
nicknamed the atrocity skull
scp-1123 is an old human skull with no
teeth or lower jaw across the forehead
region of the skull the kimira word for
remember is written in blood testing of
the skull and blood determined it was
from the 19 70s and that both the blood
and skull belong to the same person the
atrocity skull was discovered by a
colonel in the Vietnamese People's Army
in the 1980s as part of a collection of
human remains displayed in a Cambodian
Museum struck by the bloody writing and
the peculiar feeling that the skull gave
him the colonel decided to send it to
Hanoi for further investigation while in
transit though the skull was intercepted
by the SCP Foundation Foundation agent
set a trap along the road blowing up the
tires of the Colonel's Transportation
the skull was taken and sent to a
foundation facility and the colonel was
given an amnestic to remove all memory
of the skull's discovery the staff of
the Cambodian Museum received a similar
treatment all written memories of the
skull were erased and now outside of the
foundation's archives there is no
official record of the skull ever having
existed the bloody writing on the skull
has faded over time and from a distance
is barely visible at all the first SCP
Foundation agent to study the skull an
unknown researcher whose name has since
been scrubbed from the foundation
archives had a series of unusual
experiences while observing the skull he
reported that the script was invisible
from five meters away as he approached
it he noted that the writing became
clear with each meter he got closer
until at one meter away the writing
looked fresh unable to stop himself he
reached out to touch it and found that
his fingers came away slick and red
somehow the bloody writing was still wet
as if it had been drawn only moments
before as soon as he touched the text he
began to experience anomalous sensory
phenomena the room filled with the smell
of smoke he could hear the sound of
heavy breathing and the pounding of a
heartbeat there were thundering
footsteps behind him and he turned to
look but found nothing there he jerked
his hand back away from the skull
recoiling at the sensation of ants
crawling over the back of his hand his
eyes began to sting as if filled with
Ash and he stumbled backward only to
fall to the ground from a sudden
stabbing sensation Like A Shard of glass
piercing his shoe and the sole of his
foot the researcher was removed from the
room and examined by a physician who
found that none of these Sensations had
accompanying physical symptoms they were
purely psychosomatic so it seemed there
was nothing in his eyes no wound on his
foot contact with a skull had caused him
to experience these physical stimuli but
it was all in his head and this was far
from the full extent of
scp-1123's impact on those who
interacted with it after several weeks
untouched the skull was examined by yet
another Foundation researcher when she
touched the surface of the skull to lift
it and take a closer look she fell into
a dissociative Fugue State a kind of
distressing altered state of
consciousness she became confused
disoriented and wouldn't respond to her
name the skull was removed from a grasp
as soon as she became unresponsive but
this did nothing to return her to normal
the accompanying researchers simply had
to observe her and wait for her to wake
up six hours later when she finally did
she recounted what she experienced after
touching the skull she claimed that she
had seen the life of another person in
the time between touching the skull and
returning to Consciousness she could
recount details of this other person's
life describing places she had never
been the events she had never witnessed
and even speaking a language she had
previously demonstrated no command of
the other researchers determined that
the person described actually had
existed though they had since passed
away and that all the little details
were too specific to be a simple
coincidence after this encounter with
scp-1123
several other researchers experienced
similarly traumatic Fugue States the
foundation was able to identify several
shared characteristics among those who
touched the skull and experienced the
life of another person all of the people
whose memories were seen by test
subjects died before the subject was
born were a victim of violence or
imprisonment died in a tragic or violent
Way by murder starvation or infection
and died as a result of being targeted
by a political movement these patterns
led to the coining of the scp's nickname
the atrocity skull it is a skull that
forces those who touch it to relive past
atrocities in order to further
understand the nature of the skull's
effects on test subjects and the nature
of the lives it imprints on them a
series of experiments were performed by
the foundation various people of
differing cultural backgrounds were
exposed to the skull in an attempt to
determine what correlation if any there
is between someone exposed to the skull
and the type of person whose memories
they experience in the first experiment
a man of Irish and French ancestry was
told to touch the skull he immediately
collapsed and began to scream in
Armenian and resist any and all
assistance from Foundation officers when
he returned to full Consciousness he
explained that he had taken on the
memories of an Armenian farmer who was
burned alive by the ottoman Army in 1915
during the Armenian genocide during a
different experiment a man with Haitian
ancestry touched the skull just before
touching it he complained of a chemical
smell and a powerful itching sensation
after he touched it he began to
violently cough his Fugue State lasted
for 60 minutes and was characterized by
confusion and a sudden ability to speak
Kurdish after waking up from the Fugue
State the man was able to describe the
imprinted personality of an 85 year old
victim of a mustard gas attack in Iraq
in 1989. a third experiment involved a
woman with Chinese ancestry who became
unresponsive for over two hours after
touching the skull she was clearly
distressed and began to loudly weep as
the time progressed once the two hours
were up she was able to give an
interview where she described her
experience while in the Fugue State she
experienced the life of a young
Ukrainian girl who died in 1932 as a
result of violence at the hands of a
Soviet Brigade several other experiments
were also conducted producing similar
results each time the subject would
experience a Fugue State lasting from
around an hour to upwards of six hours
the experiments allowed the foundation
to determine some statistical patterns
in the personalities and memories
experienced by test subjects the more
victims that can be attributed to a
historical event the more likely it is
that a test subject will experience the
memories of someone killed in that of
event there is no apparent correlation
between the nationality of the test
subject and the nationality of the
person whose memories they will live
through while there are no negative
physical effects on test subjects who
have come into contact with the skull
there is a notable psychological impact
which can be attributed to the traumatic
nature of the memories that they were
exposed to during the course of the
experiment subjects have demonstrated
bouts of grief and oppression as well as
struggles with survivors guilt though
they themselves did not survive the
events that they witnessed they feel as
though they did in an attempt to
alleviate these psychological effects
the foundation administered several
types of amnestics to test subjects
however these were not effective and in
many cases they were actively harmful
the SCP Foundation uses a variety of
amnestic compounds as a part of its work
but none of them were effective in
treating test subjects who had been
exposed to scp-1123 three Class B
amnestics or regressive retrograde
remove the most recently formed memories
from a person's mind when these were
administered to scp-1123 test subjects
their own memories began to fade away
while the memories of their imprinted
personality remained intact if the
dosage was increased only the memories
of the atrocity would remain other
omnistics with similar functions yielded
similar and equally troubling results
the wrong memories would disappear and
the subject's original personality would
begin to give way to that of the person
the skull had imprinted on them and so
another type of amnesic was applied an
attempt to solve this issue Class E
amnestics or on Wii do not remove
memories from the subject's mind but
rather lessen the subject's emotional
response to them they are intended to
weaken the neural Pathways and remove
the emotional component from a given
memory reducing the subject's stress or
trauma response to to the information of
said memory all the signs behind this
class of amnestic suggest that it would
be beneficial to the test subjects
involved in this research but for some
reason they were still ineffective the
application of classy amnes sticks to
test subjects following exposure to the
atrocity skull only worsen the subject's
trauma response contributing to panic
attacks flashbacks and other symptoms of
severe post-traumatic stress disorder
eventually the use of amnestics to
benefit these test subjects was
abandoned entirely experimentation with
the skull was placed on hold until a
beneficial treatment program for the
test subjects could be established
currently to preserve the condition of
the skull and the writing on its surface
scp-1123 is kept contained in a
hermetically sealed container in an
Argon gas atmosphere when it is removed
from containment for experimentation and
testing it is kept in light at no more
than 50 Lux with the temperature inside
the container kept between 20 and 24
degrees Celsius and 55 percent humidity
no one is permitted to handle the skull
under any circumstances except for
controlled experimentation there is a
saying that says those who do not learn
from history are doomed to repeat it as
distressing as the experience of
touching scp-1123 may be perhaps there
is a use for it confronting historical
atrocities directly and Looking Through
The Eyes of their victims is a stark
reminder of all the evil that humanity
is capable of certainly the history
reflected by the atrocity skull
imprinted directly into the minds of all
who touch it will not be soon forgotten
those who have touched it those who
speak to them and all who learn about
the impact of the atrocity skull should
take care to remember history to learn
from it to make sure that these Evils
are never repeated again perhaps we will
even reach a point where we do not have
to look through the eyes of the victims
of institutionalized evil we will simply
have moved Beyond it then and only then
will it be time for the skull to be
destroyed until then it remains
preserved in the halls of the SCP
Foundation as a reminder that to admits
to all the horrors contained in those
walls sometimes the greatest monster is
us for a moment we want you to cast your
mind back to your childhood a time when
you weren't as busy or burdened with the
pressures of life that come as you grow
up when you were carefree and had your
whole life ahead of you nothing but
potential and opportunity a simpler time
when the highest award you could achieve
was in a grade or a promotion but
something as simple as your mom or dad
pinning a drawing you did to the door of
the refrigerator oh to be a kid again
right then again maybe returning to
younger days is better left as a fantasy
it's hard to imagine that something so
pure so simple and wholesome as a
drawing on the fridge could ever be
something dark horrific even but then
you learn about
scp-683 and all of a sudden returning to
your childhood becomes something you
hope never happens
scp-683 is an anomaly with various parts
to it so we'll start with
scp-683-1 at first glance it looks to be
just an ordinary refrigerator to be more
precise it's actually a 1953 Crosley
Salvador for any of you fridge experts
out there who are curious about the
exact make and model of
scp-683-1 for everyone else picture the
refrigerator that Indiana Jones hid
inside to miraculously survive a nuclear
blast in Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
that was such a plot device I don't know
about you guys but I'm feeling nervous
already like we said at first glance
you'd struggle to spot anything out of
the ordinary about this particular
fridge apart from maybe some slight wear
and tear on the Outside Inside though
it's perfectly clean kept in perfect
working condition for keeping food cool
but that's the first weird thing about
scp-683-1 you see despite the foundation
conducting tests to deliberately make it
Messier the fridge seems to have an
inbuilt function that you wouldn't find
in one from Home Depot it can self-clean
yes that doesn't sound all that
impressive unless you're a fridge owner
yourself and know what a nightmare they
can be to keep clean while it's
definitely weird it's not the last of
scp-683-1's anomalous properties the
next is the fact that the power cord of
this refrigerator ends with a plug that
doesn't match any known type of wall
outlet seems even stranger after all who
would design a fridge that can't even be
plugged in right in fact the SCP
Foundation had to design their very own
completely one-of-a-kind adapter to
connect scp-683-1
one to an ordinary gas-powered home
generator once plugged in though
scp-683-1 functions exactly like you
would expect any other refrigerator to
sort of it's about time we move on to
scp-683's Second component designated as
scp-683-2 again much like the fridge it
is somehow affixed to at first look this
part looks completely ordinary it's a
drawing created using felt pens and
pencils presumably by a child between
the ages of five and seven years old
there's evidence of some moderate water
damage to the paper but once again
nothing all that strange to look at even
the subject of this child's drawing is
pretty mundane just some scribbles of a
pleasant mountainous landscape a house a
well a dog a figure wearing a chef's
took and of course an anthropomorphic
sun with a smiley face now sure that
might not sound all that impressive but
we would advise you not to say anything
like that out loud criticizing the
drawing is a comment you might wish you
hadn't made just like when you fill our
comment sections with dated Among Us
memes seriously it's getting old any
person that makes any kind of negative
or disparaging remark about the
scp-683-2 drawing or tries to remove the
paper from the fridge door of
scp-683-1 will suffer a grim horrific
fate the next time they try to eat
anything this person will suffer immense
irreparable damage to their internal
organs along with their skin and muscle
tissue this is intensely painful causing
the subject agonizing pain as their
organs and skin are melted down the
amount the person loses is equal to the
massive food they've eaten with each
bite they will lose more and more of
their body the painful process will not
stop until they have ingested 0.42
kilograms of food making this even worse
the process doesn't seem to Target any
organs that would kill the subject
immediately they're made to suffer in
excruciating pain punished with torture
for daring to try and remove the drying
from the fridge any and all subjects
will die within 26 days of taking that
final bite and thus losing the last
piece of themselves but where do the
body parts of these people go surely
they don't disappear you must be
thinking and you would be right in
instances like this the third mystery
component of scp-683 is revealed
referred to as
scp-683-3 a brown paper lunch bag will
manifest inside the scp-683-1 fridge
containing a grim and grisly assortment
of meals on every occasion the bag
contains a sandwich with a pretty
disgusting filling the Flesh and viscera
of the last person who dared to
criticize the drawing on the
refrigerator there is also a plastic
Ziploc bag in which you'll find the
other half of the stolen organs and
flesh of this unlucky person along with
three chocolate chip cookies
surprisingly these are actually
completely normal cookies with no traces
of DNA or other abnormalities to them
every time there is also one final item
that forms the contents of
scp-683-3 and that's a note which reads
be a good boy today this note Bears the
same handwriting as appears on the outer
surface of the paper bag upon which a
single name is written Eric now for
those of you in the know about the
various anomalies of the SCP Foundation
that particular unassuming name might
sound very familiar it was the same name
mentioned by another anomaly known as
scp-066 a brief bit of context for you
scp-066 was a living ball of yarn that
displayed friendly Behavior towards
Foundation staff however during an
experiment a thread was cut from scp-0
66's body this caused the yarn to
transform into a ball of meat with a
pair of functional eyes protruding from
it
scp-066 became hostile constantly asking
for an Eric whenever someone gets too
close to it the same name Eric was also
found carved into the back of scp-168
another anomaly encountered by the SCP
Foundation
scp-168 was an anomalous calculator
which actually possessed some level of
sentience and had the ability to
communicate so who is Eric well theories
range far and wide but there's no real
definitive answer as to exactly who or
what Eric might be some claim he's a
reality-bending entity others pause it
he's an SCP that the foundation just
doesn't know about yet regardless he's
connected to some intriguing entities a
sentient calculator a formerly friendly
ball of yarn and a fridge with a child's
drawing on it that can steal people's
organs and put them in a lunch bag
especially for him it would seem that
Eric is a child maybe a Schoolboy
possibly even the one responsible for
the drawing on scp-683 this child could
even potentially be anomalous in nature
of course this is all just rampant
speculation on our part so it's probably
best to take all of that with a grain of
salt as we've said before it is just a
theory
nscp explained Theory Eric might just
remain one of the foundation's many
unanswered mysteries for years to come
but if that answer doesn't satisfy you
then why don't we go back to scp-683
maybe something in the fridge's origin
will give us a further clue to the
mystery of who Eric is the fridge was
first discovered by the SCP Foundation
in the storage unit of a Washington Home
owned by a woman named Yolanda as
coincidence would have it Yolanda was a
collector of vintage Home Furnishings
including refrigerators which would
probably explain why she didn't think to
throw out such an old model of fridge
from the 1950s according to her she
found scp-683 simply left on a nearby
street corner with nobody around that
could have left it there or anyone that
could have possibly been transporting it
to the local dump to give her a hand
moving the fridge Yolanda Enlisted the
help of her nephew who agreed to step in
and assist her in getting scp-683 back
to her house unfortunately though the
nephew passed away only two weeks later
apparently due to Medical complications
that came as the result of a hernia
according to his death certificate could
Yolanda's nephew have been the
mysterious and Elusive Eric could
something have happened to him after his
death that allowed him to become some
kind of anomaly who's to say we can only
guess and hope that one day we might get
a full answer as to why Yolanda never
suffered the effects of scp-683 she
never actually tried to take the
scp-683-2 drawing down from the the
fridge when asked why she simply replied
it's a nice little picture isn't it why
take it down maybe just maybe it might
have even reminded her of her nephew it
would have been a futile and foolish
idea for Yolanda to have even tried to
remove the drawing at any rate as any
who try will suffer that painful and
horrifying process of losing their
organs and having them appear in Eric's
paper lunch bag even fire can't remove
the drawing from the fridge at least not
permanently suggesting that even the
paper it is drawn on has its own
anomalous properties on three separate
occasions the SCP Foundation has
attempted to test this setting
scp-683-2 on fire with nothing more than
a match every time the drawing was
incinerated burning to ashes until there
was nothing left but within 68 hours
scp-683-2 had returned to its permanent
fixture on the fridge door as if nothing
had
interestingly though the d-class members
of personnel that were instructed to
burn the drawing didn't suffer the usual
anomalous effects of
scp-683 a similar thing happens if
multiple people attempt to remove
scp-683-2 or say anything negative
towards the drawing in cases like this
only the very first person who made a
disparaging remark or trying to rip a
drawing from the fridge will be the one
to suffer a long painful torture by
organ removal followed swiftly by death
now if you cast your mind back to
earlier in the video we told you that
someone who tries removing or disparages
as
cp683-2 will only suffer an anomalous
lack of organs when they next eat
something so you must be thinking that
the way to avoid that is to simply not
eat too fast and not ingest a single
meal and yes you'd be right that does
Stave off the anomalous effects of the
fridge and the drawing but also means
you're heading towards an even slower
painful death from starvation to date
two different Foundation test subjects
have died this way by refusing to eat
after interacting with scp-683 true the
SCP Foundation is most likely sitting on
a whole Cavalcade of different anomalies
that can keep a person alive without the
need for food but you know what they're
like right the foundation's hardly
likely to share the keys to surviving
without having to eat and there you have
it folks that's
scp-683 don't worry it's highly unlikely
that you'll ever encounter it the
foundation keeps it under lock and key
in a Cell fitted with a steel door and
reinforced hinges
scp-683 remains covered in a large cloth
to prevent any members of personnel from
looking at it when the fridge isn't
being used for research or experiments
but you have to wonder what if it's not
the only fridge with these anomalous
properties after all it's rare for a
manufacturer to make just a single
refrigerator of a certain model maybe
you'd better be wearing next time you
visit someone with an older model of
fridge in their kitchen and just to be
safe if there is a drawing pin to the
front door leave it where it is
sometimes dealing with anomalies that
could destroy the world with a flick of
their wrist can get a little old sure it
definitely wouldn't be a good thing if
the Devourer of Worlds well devoured the
world or if scp-001 when day breaks
turns us all into weird melty zombies
but it's almost impossible to conceive
the sheer scale of Destruction that an
XK Class end of the world scenario would
cause you'd almost be numb to it if you
even survived in the words of scp-2430
Creator Joseph Stalin the death of one
man is a tragedy the death of millions
is a statistic okay he didn't actually
say that but it's an appropriate quote
either way today we're talking about a
much smaller pettier kind of evil sure
this anomaly can kill people and has
many many times in fact but where it
really gets its kicks is in making you
feel like crap on a more emotional level
it's
scp-056 ironically known by the nickname
a beautiful person because on the inside
this self-obsessed monster is anything
but beautiful this crafty creature spent
what potentially could have been
hundreds of years around humans before
the SCP Foundation eventually located it
and apprehended it meaning you may have
even run into it at some point or
another before it was rightfully
imprisoned how do you know if you had a
brush with scp-056 well it's difficult
to know for sure but perhaps the biggest
indicator is that it probably annoyed
the living hell out of you you see
scp-056 is a sentient shapeshifter with
a subtle mind warping ability whose
entire reason for existence is using
those abilities to make everyone around
them feel incredibly inadequate they
don't have any kind of consistent or
True Form only a consistent ethos and
that ethos is anything you can do I can
do better and we mean this in the most
literal sense whenever scp-056 is left
with a person an animal or even an
object the second all eyes are taken off
of it it'll become a slightly better
version of whatever it's encountering if
that thing in question is capable of
thinking or feeling it will not feel
good about this development just like we
said it's probably not going to bring
the world to its knees but it sure would
suck to know
scp-056 its lack of a consistent form
makes scp-056 a little difficult to
think about visually which was also the
reason it was so hard to catch but for
the sake of consistency we'll present it
here with one of its favorite forms a
woman who's a real dead ringer for
Perfection famous actress Scarlett
Johansson of Black Widow Fame personally
I liked her as the computer in her but
that's besides the point so what is it
really like to experience
scp-056's anomalous effects first hand
well we'll take you through a little
crash course and anomalous insecurity
and frustration let's say that this
creature in human form is one of your
co-workers when the foundation
discovered it it was working in the
fashion industry but who knows what Java
could have held before then if it worked
in your office it was probably that one
irritating co-worker who always wore
nicer clothes than you had a brighter
wider smile and much better hair while
you were thanklessly toiling away on the
reports for the latest Financial quarter
zero five six was schmoozing with your
boss on golf lunches scoring perfect
games and promotions one hole in one at
a time of course they'll tell you about
it at the water cooler like everyone
else who's feeling inadequate maybe you
buy yourself a new car a vintage
Cadillac convertible that makes you feel
more like a gangster than an office
drone awesome that'll make all those
feelings that you're not good enough go
away you even buy yourself a stylish
pair of sunglasses and start cruising
around town with a top down hoping that
everyone sees how cool you are now but
when you are stopped at a red light you
see someone approaching in the lane next
to you it's the latest Rolls-Royce
Phantom in jet black and who would be
behind the wheel but
scp-056 in Armani Shades that are much
nicer than yours it Grins and nods to
you in the mirrors and you can feel your
soul shriveling up inside you only to be
replaced by rage and resentment maybe
later that month you and all your
co-workers are at a bar enjoying drinks
of course scp-056 is the best dressed
one there and is telling all the most
interesting stories your jokes don't get
it any laughs but 056 is bringing down
the house with every word feeling
ignored you decide to get everyone
around on you 056 is a designated driver
in its new Rolls-Royce so you just
decide to get them a Pepsi instead
however by the time you return to their
stool they're nowhere to be seen a tall
glass of Coca-Cola with ice cubes is
sitting on the bar next to their seat
perhaps one day you finally snap and
decide you can't take it anymore you'll
meet scp-056 after work and put the
showboating jerk in its place at long
last you sneak up on on it in an alley
with a knife in your palm and swing for
it but your blade never makes contact
scp-056 unleashes some high-level Jiu
Jitsu move on you easily knocks the
knife from your hands and beats the
living hell out of you when you're later
convicted of attempted murder all you
can do is Scream they made me do it
again and again in your prison cell Envy
can do crazy things to a person but wait
there's more really if you lose your
mind from an encounter with scp-056 you
still haven't done too badly while its
methods of attack are more commonly
psychological as we alluded to earlier
scp-056 is definitely not above
committing some pretty horrifying acts
of violence
scp-056 was discovered in its Clothing
Design job after causing an unusually
high number of murders suicides and
mental breakdowns among its co-workers
however things took an even more
unpleasant turn when the foundation sent
Personnel to detain it scp-056 reacted
poorly to the show of potential force
and turned into something even more
dangerous than the foundation plan for
it in getting under control we don't
know exactly what it transformed into
due to SCP Foundation redactions but our
guess is for what it transformed into
would either be a giant monster a
rambo-esque Unstoppable super soldier or
something like one of those huge Killer
Robots from RoboCop pick your favorite
down there in the comments but whatever
the case it caused the unfortunate
deaths of 17 agents and 10 civilians the
incident was blamed on an employee at
the company going postal and deciding to
kill a bunch of Innocents which
technically wasn't untrue not long after
Foundation operatives were able to
tranquilize as cp056 perhaps you think
this nasty little monster decided to
mellow out a bit after being contained
but if you did think that I'm afraid
you'd be dead wrong it just decided to
start terrorizing Foundation staff with
its infuriating anomalous abilities
instead wait until you see you this
compared to a lot of entities locked up
at the SCP Foundation
scp-056 really lives in the lap of
luxury it has a well-furnished room easy
access to members of staff and is given
permission to interact with any object
it desires as long as those objects
aren't anomalous why is this
euclid-class anomaly with over 17 dead
Foundation staff members to its name
given so much leeway well to answer that
remember the ethos anything you can do I
can do better and this holds true
whether we're talking about physical
appearance or one's capacity to commit
tremendous acts of violence the
foundation is forced to cater to most of
scp-056's whims or it will become a hell
of a lot more dangerous in response to
any kind of external resistance say we
told you it would suck to have known
this thing and nobody knows that better
than the employees of the SCP Foundation
who are forced to interact with it on a
daily basis for containment and testing
first let's take a look at some of the 4
forms it's occupied since it began its
time at the SCP Foundation when a
researcher brought in their beloved
Pooch
scp-056 decided to flex on it by
becoming a beautiful well-groomed
Labrador Retriever when a younger female
staff passed it it decided to once again
take on its Scarlett Johansson form when
speaking to a group of other researchers
about intelligence it became a female
researcher with an IQ score 30 points
higher than the top scoring human
researcher on site when it took a trip
to the containment site's gym where the
guards and mobile task forces exercise
and train it decided to take its flexes
to a more literal level it transformed
into a ripped hunky bodybuilder who
strutted into the middle of the gym and
bench pressed 250 kilos no problem this
was 30 kilos more than the strongest
human guard working at the site its
commitment to being the best is so great
that when left alone in its containment
chamber it was sometimes literally
transform into a nicer couch than the
one the foundation provided for it as an
just make your blood boil but wait
there's more just in case this wasn't
absurd enough the foundation felt like
testing the limits of its anomalous
abilities in particular they were
extremely eager to see if 056 had a
secret default form they left it alone
with a single security camera in order
to observe what it transformed into when
not being observed and can you guess
what happened it turned into an even
higher quality security camera and
stared back while the Transformations
can only take place while 056 isn't
being observed it's very astute at
creating periods where it can't be seen
or interacted with vision or camera
feeds have been known to briefly go
foggy in order to facilitate a
transformation it's fitting that 056
being the ultimate Diva will only ever
let people look at it on its own terms
it also seems to get off on causing
shame and the degree to which that
statement is metaphorical is well open
to interpretation staff members is made
insecure by its Antics feel compelled to
enter its cell and verbally berate it at
which .056 will shame them even harder
and send them out with their tail
between their legs it's like every toxic
friend rolled into one nasty package
curious as to what else scp-056 was
capable of the foundation conducted a
few other tests between scp-056 and
their personnel here they discovered
that 056 seemed incredibly responsive to
intent when a d-class was sent in with a
knife and the intent to kill 056
transformed into a lean athletic man
before disarming and killing the d-class
a somewhat attractive d-class female was
sent in with a bottle of wine 056 became
a beautiful woman and accepted the wine
before taking a sip and spitting it back
into the d-class's face a mixed gender
pair of d-classes were sent in next with
no real intent 056 became an attractive
woman in a well-tailored business suit
who looked over the pair before kicking
them both out 10 male d-classes were
sent in after that 056 turned into a
beautiful woman in a low-cut dress and
simply waited until the 10 men were
driven mad with desire and began
physically fighting one another for her
affection she watched them doing this
for seven minutes before laughing and
leaving the synth Squadron to Duke it
out alone in another test a female staff
member with level 4 clearance who was
also judged to be the most attractive
woman on site which seems like an HR
issue that the Ethics Committee should
probably look into was sent into 056's
testing chamber 056 became quote an
extremely aesthetically pleasing woman
who displayed a large lexicon and
understanding of management skills
unquote the two spoke for around 90
minutes until the level 4 staff member
stormed out in a rage recently 056 has
requested access to the internet saying
that the foundation has been unable to
provide it with enough syncopants and
that via the Internet the whole world
will be able to see its face if ever
zero five 56 got onto YouTube and
transformed into a more successful SCP
Channel I just don't think we'd be able
to take it thankfully this request was
denied legends about the end of the
world often come with the sounds of
thundering Hooves and the approach of
Four Horsemen War famine pestilence
death they will descend on the world and
Usher in the end of days it's a
terrifying idea these Horsemen bringing
darkness and Decay wherever they go as
the world collapses all around them we
all hope that we'll never see the day
that the four horsemen come
unfortunately some lucky people out
there have already encountered their own
version of the Horsemen of the
Apocalypse shadowy riders with inhuman
strength that follow disaster
destruction and Untold suffering the SCP
Foundation came across a series of
journal entries written by Dave harken
an infantryman in the British
expeditionary force during World War one
that first World War was a nightmare for
all who fought in it a sea of Bloodshed
and gunfire young men crouched terrified
in foxholes and wondering when death
would finally come for them the horrors
of War are notable but not exactly the
sort of thing the SCP Foundation
preoccupies itself with so what was so
captivating so specifically terrible
about Dave Harkin's journals they
described his experiences over the
course of the battle of the psalm and an
anomaly he encountered there that was
unlike anything he had ever seen no
military training no combat experience
could have prepared him for what was
waiting hiding in the fog of War his
first journal entry began on a
lighthearted note or as lighthearted as
one can be in the face of combat June 27
1916 finally arrived at the front I
picked up this little Journal while I
was in Paris figured I might as well
keep record of my heroics on the
battlefield quite chopped to finally be
an action though it seems I'm the only
one most of these blokes have been
fighting for a couple months now and
they look downright Dreadful muddle over
the uniform and their faces are so pale
look like they haven't eaten or slept
for months a few days later he began to
hear stirrings amongst his fellow
soldiers and strange sounds that rocked
their Barracks he described the first
unsettling incident July 2nd 1916 woke
in the early hours of the morning ground
was shaking damn near shook me out into
the muck on The Dugout floor Paul blokes
in the bunks on the other side looked
like they had seen a ghoul pair of
Northern Irish Lads from kitchener's
armies if I remember right kept
muttering about a Nocatee who both
gripping the gold crucifix was about to
lay my head back down and get a wink of
shut eye when I ended up scrambling into
the mud loudest damn thing I'd ever
heard but it was the Hun artillery about
Demarcus with a whiz-bang only problem
was never did get the bang this morning
asked our brass hat about the artillery
barrage gave me a funny look and that's
what the bloody hell I was talking about
the next day Dave went searching for the
source of the loud sound he didn't find
any evidence of artillery but instead
found something he had never seen before
it was a crater shaped like a giant
horse's hoof he brushed it off as just
another Oddity of the battlefield a bit
strange but nothing to be concerned
about there were more important things
at hand anyway the next day he finally
saw combat first hand and things only
got more bizarre and frightening July 3
1916 Huns made a push today first time
they moved into our region first time
I'd ever seen combat it's not romantic
and adventurous it's terrifying and
deadly my hands can't stop shaking
already messed up the once the Hans
had her outfitting up against the wall
damn near overranus didn't help that it
rained that night before making a
foxhole filled to the brim with muck one
of the fritz came right at ninjas I put
one right between his eyes fell right at
the edge of the trench had to look at
him in the eyes while land couldn't have
been more than 7 19 or 18 Martin one of
the Irish Lads is gone was unlike
anything I'd ever seen one moment he's
standing shooting at Huns all of a
sudden the mud starts boiling for anyone
can react mud just flies everywhere
everyone else is suddenly knocked down
off their feet I look up and he's just
gone wasn't even body parts left haven't
told anyone but I'd swear that there
were bones coming from underneath him
right before the mud went flying his
mate Brendan was digging in the mud for
hours looking for the crucifix Martin's
body was never found no matter how they
searched a little over a week later
things got even worse July 14th and 15
1916 puns tried to push this morning in
the rain I was in the Machine Gun Nest
with Brendan the other Irish chap in my
unit they kept coming and coming and
getting stuck in the mud and I just kept
shooting sun is rising I'm on watch till
at least eight at least that's what the
brass had said I've started losing track
of how much time's been passing there's
something thing out there something
lurking out in the mud and dead Huns
nearly dozed off last night listening to
the moans of the bloody wounded stuck
out in no man's land Paul's Souls got
left behind saw something out of the
edge of my vision something big couldn't
quite make it out it was much darker
than usual overcast sky was obscuring
the full moon put a couple of Screams
but whatever it was was gone before my
flare hit the sky this would not be
Dave's Last sighting of the large dark
figure this mysterious Shadow would
appear again several days later and
there would be more of them July 30th
1916 I've been seeing them at the edge
of my vision ever since that first night
they're huge they move so damn fast that
they're gone before I can get a clear
look or at least that's how it was
mucking out until today thick fog and
Mist rolled in this morning blanketed
everything we figure the Huns might use
it to launch another push bastards have
been pushing non-stop since the 20th saw
it through the fog looked like a shadow
hiding in the Mist some sort of
horse-like creature with something
dragging along the ground and a giant
lump where the rider would sit said the
lump started moving could have sworn it
was a person of something that looked
like a person sat up and the things
dragging along the ground reached out in
front of it and picked up something
thought it was a couple dead Jerry's
until they started squirming I'll never
forget the noise it made louder than a
Banshee shrill and twisted it looked
right at me two pairs of red glowing
orbs two weeks after meeting eyes with
this chilling Apparition Dave wrote a
short note in this journal August 5th
Brennan caused them nucleaves won't tell
me much more than that beginning to
understand why all these blokes look so
terrified when I first arrived it wasn't
until another week passed that Dave
would truly begin to understand just
what kind of monster he was up against
not the enemy soldiers but something far
more horrible something inhuman August
13th bloody hell the nightmare been on
watch two nights in a row one just
appeared right there right in front of
me 20 feet had to be at least 20 feet
away towering into the sky got my flight
to go off in time just to see it pick up
a couple wounded Jerry's in the mud they
don't have bloody skin they're just
muscle and fat the thing on its back
wasn't human no way it could be human
had no skin either no legs just moved
straight into the horse at the stomach I
took a couple shots at it with my rifle
did absolutely nothing like I was
shooting it with a slingshot it stopped
as my flare reached its highest point in
turn hooked straight down at me both the
horse and the thing on its back it
smiled he tried to warn his superiors
try to warn of the horrors he was seeing
in the danger he felt they posed but
they wouldn't listen night after night
the creatures came back August 17 1916
been assigned night watch the past four
nights straight try to tell the brass
had about the nooklives didn't believe
me said it was the shell shock playing
with my head how to put a sock in it and
keep on it keeps coming back every night
same spot 20 feet in front of me picks
up wounded Jerry's turns and looks and
then it's gone he plays with me I'm sure
of it last night there was another one
too for those things on its back did the
same damn thing a few days later Dave
spotted something that made his blood
run cold 7 AM August 20th 1916 Jerry's
made a big push yesterday rained two
days ago all day so the muck was deep we
were on the machine gun again in the
pillbox so many of them in no man's land
last night couldn't tell the Dead from
the living haven't slept in six days
there were five tonight three of them
had more than one of those things on
their back the one that keeps coming
back dropped something sought shine in
the flare light 10 a.m August 20th 1916
went out into the mud where it appears
every night found Martin's crucifix and
Tin hat whatever this thing was it had
taken Martin it seemed to want Dave to
know that too he left behind Martin's
lost things for him to find as if it was
gloating as if it already knew that it
had won August 20th 1916 the getting
bold saw one out in broad daylight
pretty sure it was the same one buried
itself in the mud just lying there
waiting we're going over the top at
three they're more out there now while
doing the same thing God help us Dave
Heartland was declared missing an action
on August 20th 1916 following an
attempted counter-attack against the
German forces another soldier from his
unit Brendan O'Malley was also reported
missing in action on the same day though
Dave's Body was never recovered his
journal was found 20 feet away from the
edge of the German trenches two months
later or Dave Harkin had no idea what he
and the rest of his fellow soldiers
encountered out there he didn't live to
learn more but he came face to face with
scp-3456
scp-3456 is not one being but rather a
group of quadrupeds that that vaguely
resemble horses from a distance their
silhouette looks like that of a horse
with a human riding on its back however
once the Observer gets closer they will
notice some disturbing differences these
creatures do not look like any ordinary
horse they are smooth and hairless with
translucent skin and three-toed Hooves
anyone unfortunate enough to get close
to one of these creatures will be able
to see through their skin to the blood
vessels and muscle underneath they will
also notice that there was no Rider
perched Atop The Creatures back at all
the humanoid shape is part of the
creature's body an extension of them
fused to its back the humanoid figure
consists of a pair of long arms which
drags along the ground as the creature
moves and ahead the arms end in
sharpened bones rather than fingers and
the head has mostly human features with
the exception of a hole where the nose
should be the creatures vary greatly in
size but the largest on record measuring
at a height of 30 meters and a width of
15. the they appear to be invulnerable
at least when it comes to any
traditional human Weaponry they have
currently been exposed to gunfire
explosives swords and arrows and even
nuclear blasts seem to have no effect if
you happen to get a good look at one of
these bulletproof Abominations in person
then I am so sorry you are as good as
gone because once you have seen one of
these creatures they have also seen you
and they will not stop until they have
taken you they will track you stalk you
hide buried in mud and nestled in bushes
they will wait for the opportune moment
and they will reach out with their
unnaturally long arms smiling with no
lips as their blood red eyes burn like
Hellfire and you will disappear forever
they will travel far beyond the site
where they first appeared until they
have finally captured their prey this
isn't an scp-096 situation either they
aren't punishing you for seeing their
face they want to be seen and and will
go out of their way to show themselves
to people until they have captured as
many as they want no one knows what
becomes of
scp-3456's victims but they are never
seen again though items once belonging
to the missing people may resurface
their bodies are never found there is
only one way to escape from
scp-3456 and that is to find and cross a
body of fresh water for reasons unknown
the entities are unable or unwilling to
cross rivers streams and lakes the
foundation first discovered this during
an operation in Iraq in which several
agents encountered a group of
scp-3456 manifestations they fled from
the monsters and quickly retreated
across the Tigris River once they had
reached the other side they saw that the
creatures had not followed them onto the
bridge instead they remained at the
riverbank on the other side watching and
waiting this was quickly noted and added
to potential containment procedures
though the exact reason for scp-3450 6's
dislike of fresh water is currently
unknown in Dave heartland's journals his
fellow Soldier described the creatures
as nucleaves but would not elaborate
beyond that so what is a nuclei the word
refers to a creature from the Waters of
orkney a group of islands on the
northern coast of Scotland their name is
thought to come from an orcitian word
meaning devil of the sea and they truly
are like something out of hell these
creatures are native to the ocean and
supposedly take on another form when in
their natural habitat but no one knows
what they truly look like on land the
creature is a hybrid of a man and horse
with a large snout like that of a pig
and a single red eye that burns like the
Embers of a fire it has no hair or skin
just raw tissue and Bone dripping black
blood everything about the creature is
malicious and deadly intended to bring
harm and Calamity to humans even its
breath is toxic thought to cause disease
plague and the death crops as they are
native to the ocean they detest fresh
water and will not cross it even in
pursuit of their prey they will also not
appear when it is raining in the Legends
of the nuclei they do have a natural
enemy a creature from Arcadian folklore
known as the mither of the sea is said
to have the power to keep the monsters
from coming ashore during the summer
months the mither or mother is a
benevolent force of nature giving warmth
to the oceans and life to the beings on
the water and the land though scp-3456
has appeared during the summer months it
has never been spotted in the orkney
region during this time of year perhaps
this is a coincidence but some
Foundation researchers have proposed a
research expedition to the area in order
to look for the kindly ocean spirit so
far this proposal has been denied
scp-3456 is classified as ketter and
there is currently no way to effectively
contain it all previous attempts to
contain or to neutralize the horsemen
have failed though the foundation is
always looking for new methods to
attempt currently any Personnel who see
the horsemen will be given class GMA
sticks at a treatment center located
within one kilometer of a freshwater
stream river or lake all references to
the horsemen have been scrubbed from
historical records and any sightings are
to be blamed on PTSD shock and
trauma-induced hysteria areas that are
likely to attract
scp-3456 such as War zones and areas
impacted by natural disasters are to be
heavily monitored by the foundation in
the event of a disaster Foundation
Personnel will be sent to help with
evacuation in order to get all civilians
away from scp-3456 as quickly as
possible so what is
scp-3456 is it the dreaded nut clay from
folk tales and whispered Fireside
warnings there are some notable
differences between the stories and what
the foundation encountered
scp-3456 does not seem to have come from
the ocean nor is it limited to only
appearing around orkney these beasts
seem to manifest from thin air and
disappear the same way when their nasty
work is done but folklore and passing
down stories often distorts things
details change and others are added or
left out in the Original Stories the
nuclei were thought to be the cause of
famines plagues and disasters perhaps it
was simply drawn to these events lure
there by the scent of pure human misery
perhaps the nucleive is not just similar
to
scp-3456 but the two are one and the
same or perhaps they are something
entirely different whatever the case may
be there is nothing we can do to stop
them War famine pestilence and death are
everywhere they are inevitable and
unfortunate parts of life on Earth so it
seems are these deadly Riders these
monsters that are neither horse nor man
but still somehow both every time we
wage war every time disaster strikes
they will come to watch to pick through
the rubble and to smile maybe we don't
need to dread the coming of the Horsemen
of the Apocalypse they are already here
there are many things in this world that
we do not and perhaps cannot understand
the SCP Foundation dedicates itself to
researching and containing these things
but even they occasionally encounter
something that defies any kind of true
understanding the unknown is terrifying
to the average person but for an
organization that specializes in knowing
the unknowable a mystery that refuses to
be understood can be downright
nightmarish a foundation Expedition team
lost contact with their command while on
a mission in the northern Ural Mountains
of Russia after six hours of Silence
radio contact was re-established though
video feed continued to be disabled a
loan agent Dr fellenstein called out
desperately over the radio waves begging
for someone anyone to answer him command
responded requesting a status update on
the rest of his crew at first they were
met only with the wet Hollow sound of
felonstein weeping finally he explained
that they were all dead and that he was
the only man left standing
something hot to him he said a fellow
agent Myers it was long slippery I saw a
grown man pulled into a tiny hole he
began to hyperventilate his descriptions
becoming less and less coherent command
offered to send reinforcements to
collect the Survivor but he begged them
not to he was beyond saving at this
point describing himself as nothing but
a Walking Corpse after slipping into a
crevice Valenstein had broken his ankle
and torn a hole in his hazmat suit
command honored his insistence that no
reinforcements be sent in but encouraged
him to try and pull himself back to the
surface and retrieve additional data
even if he was doomed he could still
provide valuable information on the
threat he encountered while felon scene
attempted to free himself from the
crevice He Slipped deeper into the crack
in the ground pushing through his fear
of being crushed to death he tried again
fighting against the burning of the
toxic air in his lungs and the straining
of his muscles he finally pulled himself
to Freedom then he took in his
surroundings he was at the edge of a
Chasm so deep he could not see the
bottom he posited that he was somewhere
underneath or inside of a mountain there
was a putrid smell in the air burning
his eyes his skin everything command
told him to remain calm still hoping for
the possibility of a rescue meanwhile on
their end hostile forces were closing in
and forcing them to evacuate they asked
Valenstein to continue describing his
surroundings so that his account might
be recorded for the archives they would
attempt to come back with reinforcements
when it was safe for them to do so as
felenstein made it deeper into the chasm
he was engulfed in a thick yellow fog
through the haze he could make out
thousands of eggs and piles of meat
being devoured by small creatures with
the bodies of grubs and the faces of
human infants the creatures did not
respond to his presence either unaware
of him or too consumed with their
feeding to care as he passed the
creatures he spotted a massive black
Temple with architecture like nothing he
had seen before all polished and sharp
with angles that hurt his eyes to look
at as he stopped to take a better look
he realized he was still moving somehow
without moving his feet he was being
dragged by something tendrils wrapped
around his legs and pulling him along
against his will leaving a trail of his
blood behind as he was dragged dozens of
what seemed like humans watched him the
final words recorded on the audio
transcript were the most troubling of
all fallenstein saw what he described as
an angel with a thousand Wings the angel
pulled him into her Embrace clutching
him to her breast and the connection was
lost Dr fellenstein was never seen again
his colleague's bodies were never
recovered the entire team of men was
lost forever inside the incomprehensible
hell hole known as
scp-2133
scp-2133 is an unnamed Village in the
northern Ural Mountains in Eastern
Europe with an estimated popular
relation of around 50 people the village
is considered dangerous to enter without
proper Hazmat gear due to the presence
of a wide variety of microbial pathogens
within its limits including those which
cause leprosy mnemonic septemic and
bubonic plagues typhoid fever influenza
cholera and smallpox a veritable
hypochondriac's worst nightmare in spite
of this cocktail diseases in which they
live the residents of 2133 seem to be
resistant to the negative effects of
infection of course they experience
physical symptoms to the point of
visible disfigurement or disability but
they do not die at a rate consistent
with the sheer volume of deadly
pathogens present in their town the
people of scp-2133 do not leave it the
foundation cannot fully determine
whether they cannot leave or simply
choose not to but whatever the case may
be they stay within the limits of their
Village their relative resistance to
disease small population and refusal to
leave the boundaries of their Village
are all unusual but that is far from the
most most unusual thing about the
population of
scp-2133 the people of the village age
and die yes but they do not stay dead
they engage in what can only be
described as some kind of reincarnation
when a resident of the village dies they
are placed in the field where they
quickly Decay on the night of the First
new moon a newborn infant is pulled from
the soil where the decaying body once
lay the reborn version of each person
looks like their previous self and
Carries all of the memories they had in
their previous life the foundation
performed extensive soil tests on the
field where this curious rebirth takes
place and found that the soil bear
contains high levels of embryonic fluid
beyond the presence of this fluid in the
earth it is unknown how exactly this
reincarnation process works the
residents of the village known as
scp-2133-1 speak an old Russian dialect
and occasionally agreed to be
interviewed by Foundation staff fluent
in the style act though they will sit
for interview views and chat with
Foundation Personnel they are secretive
about their lives their history and the
culture of their little village the
first resident to be successfully
interviewed was an elderly man named
aristica who was missing his left arm
and had necrosis on most of his visible
skin the interview was conducted by Dr
Judith Lowe one of the head researchers
on the case she asked the man how far
back he was able to remember and he
recounted a time of czars and cons when
Dr Lowe pressed the man about the
rebirth that his people practice he
responded that it was the Church of the
red Harvest we serve until the end that
is the terms of our agreement Dr Lowe
asked him why he and the rest of his
people would continue to live their
lives this way when it caused them such
obvious suffering he explained simply
there is no choice the land calls we
answer she continued to push the issue
inquiring about how this all began so
many years ago he explained that a
priestess came to the valley many many
lifetimes ago she offered the people
Paradise in exchange for their servitude
however as the years passed the people
became more and more exhausted they
feared they had failed somehow and were
being punished aristakov became visibly
upset at this point in the interview but
continued to insist the Church of the
red Harvest is truth there is no other
the second interview was conducted Again
by Dr Judith Lowe who spoke with Anya a
young girl who appeared to be between
the ages of six and eight Lo greeted the
girl and attempted to ask her the first
question but Anya simply said you don't
belong here leave low brushed this off
and offer the girl medical assistance
but was rebuffed again you are not of
the Covenant you will never understand
Dr Lowe asked Anya to elaborate on the
nature of this Covenant and her
explanation was similar to that of the
previous interviewee there was an
agreement made a long time ago and now
the people of the village would serve
until the end of time again she and
insisted that the foundation should
leave and did not belong in the town
finally irritated with the questions
Anya had only this to say about the
church the church was here long before
the village a church of stone beneath
the Earth it is sacred a church of wood
was built to top it for the hearsay of
the Cross before we embrace the true
Faith the karcissist Alka will Enlighten
you you are only alive because she has
chosen to let you live hearing the word
karsus probably gives you some
indication as to what's really going on
here if the disease corruption and
mutation of the flesh didn't give you
enough of a clue this horror is sarcic
through and through Dr Lowe's final
question was a seemingly easy one does
the village have a name as soon as the
words left Dr Low's lips Anya began to
vomit up a thick black substance ending
the interview instances of
scp-2133-1 are largely apathetic towards
Foundation agents unless they get in the
way of their routine the agents are
allowed to go inside any of the
buildings in the village with one
notable exception the Church of the red
Harvest any attempts to learn more about
the church or enter its walls are met
with refusal to explain or in some cases
outright hostility though the villagers
are largely peaceful toward the
foundation they are not the only entity
living in scp-2133 throughout the
village there are instances of something
known as
scp-2133-2 these organic structures
which have the appearance of dark red
tentacles display overt hostility
towards Outsiders and will attack any
that get too close they are especially
aggressive to any Outsiders that attempt
to enter the church tissue samples were
taken from the tentacles for observation
and they were found horrifyingly enough
to genetically resemble tissue samples
from humans after the interview with
Anya the foundation research team
determined that entering the church was
of the utmost importance mobile task
force beta 7 was dispatched for this
mission and after the residents of the
Town were restrained a team of 12
operatives was sent in they were armed
with radios video recorders hazmat suits
and air tanks as they attempted to enter
the church the tentacles attacked but
were subdued with flamethrowers
apparently like most living things they
are not immune to fire inside the church
the research team found small Idols
crafted from bone and leather and a few
others made from tumors hanging from
Iron hooks on the ceiling at the
building center was an entrance to a
system of caves and caverns Beneath The
Village stretching Beyond its borders
into the mountains several previously
unseen organisms designated only as
scp-2133-3 were discovered inside one
was terminated and taken back to the
foundation for an autopsy the creature
was humanoid in nature with swollen
organs and flesh and an overgrowth of
bone and fatty tissue after the autopsy
the team of operatives refreshed their
air tanks and headed back into the
village to continue their research about
out 50 minutes into their expedition all
contact was lost out of nowhere six
hours later Dr felenstein would make his
Infamous radio contact and the nightmare
would unfold from there currently
scp-2133 is easily contained a secure
perimeter is maintained at the 10
kilometer radius around the town
preventing any civilians from making
their way inside there are guards
positioned along the perimeter under the
guise of a Russian military base in
spite of the horrifying nature of
scp-2133 the villagers do not seem to
pose an immediate threat to anyone they
simply want to be left alone to till the
fields and attend their Church in an
endless cycle of winters and Summers as
they wait for the end to come as they
hope that finally their agreement will
be honored and that they will find peace
the ocean is a terrifying Place we've
all heard the statistics more than 80
percent of the ocean remains unexplored
that's most of the water covering the
lobe completely unmapped and unobserved
by science it's a scary thought to dwell
on realizing that there's more water
than land on Earth and the sheer expanse
of that water is so large that we've
been unable to fully explore all of it
just think there are places in the ocean
that have never been seen by a human who
knows what's down there if there was
ever a personification of fear of the
unknown the ocean could definitely be it
ancient shipwrecks sunk to the ocean
floor unknown sea creatures hiding away
from humanity and the general isolation
of the suffocating dark blue the ocean
swallows its victims with all of these
images that come to mind when thinking
about the vast and mysterious deaths of
the sea and no one is more familiar with
nautical Mysteries than the SCP
Foundation today we'll be taking a look
at
scp-5007 the Bass Strait a wave of
oceanic anomalies fit to make any
seasoned sailor shiver in fear the
straight is an area of ocean dividing
Tasmania and the Australian Mainland
it's also the location of an unusually
high amount of disappearances Sailors
disappearing from their ships fishermen
leaving in the night and never coming
back even civilians disappearing from
the shores that connect to the strait
the foundation was aware of these
disappearances since 1858 but were only
able to craft theories about what was
causing them wasn't an anomalous group
of Interest hostile aerial entities
patrolling the skies above the strait
phenomenon associated with unidentified
flying objects what about Subterranean
anomalies weather patterns or time
dilation for nearly a century the
foundation was unable to determine the
cause of the high number of
disappearances in the Bass Strait and
then the phenomenon suddenly revealed
itself in 1980 on a beach connected to
the strait agent taverner an operative
of the SCP Foundation was vacationing
with his wife Mary and his three young
children the Tabernacle family was
simply enjoying their day when they saw
what looked like balloons in the sky
they were approaching quickly and
naturally the family moved closer what
happened next was a whirlwind and those
balloons the family were so interested
in Lifted them up from the ground and
carried them away agent taverner tried
to fight back but there was nothing he
could do except report to the foundation
what had occurred and the organization
responded in full force the foundation's
research discovered that reports of UFOs
and lights in the sky had coincided with
many disappearances in the strait and
that this was a pattern the search for
the four lost taverner family members
had become a large-scale investigation
into unexplained disappearances along
the Bass Strait and within three weeks
it was determined that these patterns
were consistent across the entirety of
The Straits coastal regions some
witnesses were interviewed but the vast
majority of these abduction cases had no
Witnesses whatsoever of the minimal
reports filed the Foundation was told
that there were lights in the sky and
that appearance of unidentified flying
objects described as having the
appearances of balloons one such witness
interviewed was a man by the name of
Alan Stewart a witness who was present
during The Disappearance of former
Australian prime minister Harold Holt
whose disappearance the foundation
believed may have had a connection to
the bastrate anomalies during the
interview Stewart claimed that Holt and
his family while voyaging on their yacht
decided to leave the boat and go for a
swim Holt turned to Stewart and asked
him if he could see the balloons around
the cliff Stewart had no idea what Holt
was talking about but Holt was insistent
on seeing them he swam deeper out into
the ocean saying that they weren't
normal balloons and that there was
someone inside of them Steward and
halt's family called out for him to come
to shore but he wouldn't listen Stewart
tried to rationalize what he saw next
maybe it was the current sweeping halt
away but he couldn't lie to the
foundation interviewer Stewart saw Holt
go further and further out into the
water her and suddenly the Prime
Minister turned around he began swimming
in the opposite direction and he was
screaming suddenly Holt was lifted from
the sea and pulled into the air by
something emerging from the clouds the
foundation thanks Stuart for the
interview and continued their
investigation two years later in 1982
Emergency Services received a large
number of calls pertaining to UFO
sightings off the coast of Norman Bay
Victoria the foundation was quick to
respond alerting task forces and local
sites to prepare for an investigation
upon arriving to the scene they
confirmed the existence of multiple
entities that would later be documented
as
scp-5007 they evacuated civilians from
the area and successfully managed to
capture the creature which was later
transported to site-40 for containment
it was a sight to Behold The Entity now
designated
scp-5007-s-1 was a cluster of human
bodies fused between a grouping of black
tentacles of varying length each
tentacle was fused to the skin it
touched directly the stomachs of the
corpses were grossly swollen and
distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gases inside the buoyancy
of which The Entity used to achieve a
passive flight across the entity's
surface were clusters of eyes and
bioluminescent glowing organs many of
the humanoid components of the corpses
appear to have been removed and
misplaced across various parts of the
entity's body what's more is that the
foundation discovered that human
portions of scp-5007 appeared somewhat
cognizant and aware of their situation
their vocalizations were incoherent and
barely understandable consisting of
gasping and whimpering but the corpses
were observed to implore other
individuals to approach them when
encountered
scp-5007's behavior during abduction
scenarios was documented during the
initial containment event and due to the
foundation's painstaking research a
pattern was established between all SCP
5007 encounters first the victim would
be alone or otherwise vulnerable in a
coastal location
scp-5007 haven't shown a preference for
weather be they clear or hostile Skies
but they have localized all their
activity to the best Strait in small
coastal towns beaches or boats
scp-5007 will then move towards the
shore stalking the victim before
lowering its tentacles and appendages to
grab the individual snatching them into
the sky an scp-5007 instance can even
abduct multiple people at once one event
observed had eight men from the decks of
a commercial fishing boat taken into the
sky in under 15 seconds once captured
scp-5007 instances will Dart across the
water at a high speed and take their
victims to an unknown location
discovering where scp-5007 took their
victims became a top priority for the
foundation after extensive witness
interviews and compiling a database of
likely victims the they determined that
there must be at least 16 instances of
scp-5007 unaccounted for personnel kept
a close watch on the coastlines and
Waters of the Bass Strait and equipped
various Marine task forces with research
vessels capable tracking any instances
if they encountered them in 1985 the
foundation's research efforts paid off
and several survey teams operating in
the area reported the sighting of an
extremely large
scp-5007 instance heading towards a
coastal town a mobile task force was
sent to track the entity the team
observed The Entity from afar as it
stocked a private fishing boat even from
the distance Foundation Personnel
recognized the likenesses of several
missing persons as faces of the corpses
of scp-5007 the task force Captain had
to remind his team to keep it together
claiming that they were not people but
just parts of the specimen but everyone
secretly knew the truth the fishing
vessel was a private one occupied by a
small family
The Entity slowly approached and quickly
pulled a woman into the air the family
panicked and quickly tried to reach
cover for safety running into the Ship's
Cabin The Entity ran its tentacles along
the boat until it pulled the door open
snatching another two victims the task
force was unable to help them as their
mission was to track the instance to its
origin point it was a horror to watch
the task force implanted a tracking
Beacon onto the entity and quietly
followed it out to sea over the next
four hours they then discovered a large
gray Reef with several shipwrecks dotted
across it 13
scp-5007 instances floated over the area
some holding on to the land Reef with
their tentacles The Entity dropped the
abductees from the fishing boat who were
coerced by the entities into diving into
a massive pool of water located in the
center of the reef one by one each
abductee was pulled below the surface by
something lurking in the pool all while
the scp-5007 instances watched disgusted
the task force reported what they
observed to the main site and the reef
would be designated as
scp-5007-a the foundation's analysis of
the reef led to the discovery that The
Rock covering its seeped iron oxide from
an unknown source and the Rocks achieved
growth at an anomalously fast rate often
as little as 40 minutes all of the
wrecked ships and aircraft that washed
across the shore of the reef were
covered with a dark stone The Reef was
teeming with anomalous marine life
including
scp-5007 a red algae that fed upon the
freshly grown Rock Marine worms capable
of levitation spiders that lived in silk
Retreats underneath the water line small
fish and giant organisms resembling
large clumps of kelp which the
foundation had previously documented
sscp 4159 in a separate investigation
scp-5007 often rested their tentacles on
the outcroppings of the reef while
inactive but what caught the
foundation's attention the most was the
giant pit located in the reef center
unmanned exploration drones found that
it had a depth of at least 4 000 meters
and water samples taken from the pit
revealed large quantities of human DNA
prehistoric bacteria and unknown
compounds that possess significant
life-preserving qualities when a being
was submerged in the compound they were
able to survive heavy injuries even when
fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe the foundation's
exploration of one of these shipwrecks
LED them to a journal most of it was
illegible due to water damage but one
passage survived located in the back of
the book it detailed the experience of
an unknown crew member of the ship
caught in a storm it reads mostly spied
land ahead and the boys said that there
are giant balloons hanging over the
island we are all a feared but there's
not we can do but Beach ourselves and
help for rescue should I be killed in
the crash I want my Mage to give this
journal to my Mary might know I spent my
last thinking only of her the interior
clear the ship contained human remains
inside but there were less skeletons
than the foundation would expect for a
ship of its size the location of the
rest of the bodies was unknown another
event related to scp-5007 the foundation
documented involved Frederick valentic a
pilot engaged in a training flight over
the Bass Strait in 1978. valentic's
disappearance was marked by his latest
communication with air traffic control
when he mistook an scp-5007 instance for
an unidentified aircraft it seems like
it's stationary what I'm doing right now
is orbiting and the thing is just
orbiting on top of me also it's got a
green light and sort of metallic like
it's all shiny on the outside shortly
after this valentix transmission was
interrupted by what was described as
metallic scraping sounds believed to be
the scp-5007 instance attacking the
aircraft and jamming its propellers with
its mass after crashing into the reef it
was believed that valentic and his
aircraft were pulled beneath the surface
of the pit just as the had been prior
the foundation decided to construct a
provisional secure research facility on
the reef they named it site 40-r and
documented all returns and departures of
scp-5007 they also set up a series of
containment procedures that resulted in
an scp-5007 returning with its victims
83 percent less often than before the
site's construction but this was
short-lived in 2008 the site logged over
36 instances returning to the reef with
only two not having any fresh abductees
the instance's origins were unknown and
it was as if they appeared out of thin
air no other monitoring post had
documented their appearance or even
spotted them before they arrived at The
Reef it was years later in 2017 that the
foundation eventually was able to
successfully explore what was deep
inside the pit at the center of the reef
they already knew that there was a large
entity lurking beneath as evidenced by
what happened to the victims of scp-5
2007 that were later deposited inside
the pool all previous attempts to
explore the pool were met with failure
as the water pressure of the Pit's
depths caused all craft to collapse due
to Hull damage this time however they
managed to construct a high-tech
submarine labeled the scps Nautilus
which was capable of diving a maximum of
13 500 meters underwater they decided
that a d-class Personnel would be
trained to man The submersible and carry
out the exploration the mission was
simple the Nautilus was to dive to the
bottom of the pit and to describe the
depth readings cameras and microphones
were equipped to the vessel due to the
depth remote viewing of the footage was
impossible instead the foundation had to
physically recollect the vessel in order
to view the footage upon recovery some
of the footage suffered data corruption
but what was there shook those who
viewed it to their core the footage
showed the d-classes experience going
deeper inside the pit at first it seemed
ordinary the trench had a number of
Rocky outcrops toppings dotted with
black yellow Vines growing along the
walls also present were various marine
life forms such as the spiders or the
fish going deeper the sub observed an
scp-5007 instance clinging to an
outcropping several tendrils emerging
from the Pit's depths were wrapped
around the instance and holding on to
the entity as if it were feeding from it
another 16
scp-5007 instances were seen resting
along the walls each clinging to the
outcropping as the sub went deeper the
d-class remarked that there were dozens
of plane and shipwrecks but also well
over a hundred scp-5007 entities most of
them were held there by the black
tendrils the d-class as the sub went
even deeper began noticing human remains
no short amount of them either deep into
the pit there was a large mass of human
remains covering the entirety of the pit
bodies crushed and drained of blood but
still possessing intact eyes each
individual was still alive kept
preserved by the life-sustaining
compounds found within the water the
body stared at the sub and moved
attempting to grab onto the vehicle the
d-class swore they were trying to say
something mouthing words to the camera
of the sub as the sub passed through the
massive bodies it emerged into a
completely dark black clearing at the
bottom of the pit for a second the
d-class thought he was safe but then a
large black tentacle rapidly emerged
from below and grabbed onto the Nautilus
dragging it even further Into the Depths
the d-class screamed and panicked but
there was nothing he could do the
tentacle possessed a large cluster of
eyes mouths and human heads seemingly
grafted onto its mass and then there was
another tentacle and then another the
Nautilus was pulled to the bottom of the
pool the d-class's screams were still
heard even as the picture cut out
sometimes graphic body altering images
of the tentacles features were visible
on the screen but most of the footage
was indecipherable after minutes of
distorted corrupted footage the Nautilus
was seen again rapidly ascending to the
surface somehow it had managed to escape
the entity at the bottom of the pit upon
recovery of The Craft it was found that
the Nautilus was covered in a thick
organic coating similar to a black slime
mold but with dozens of eyes growing
from it the d-class inside showed severe
psychological damage and attempted to
harm Foundation Personnel they were
terminated shortly after due to being a
danger to those around them following
review of the footage the Nautilus was
to be dismantled and incinerated along
with the remains of the d-class a
reinforced containment seal was fitted
over the pit with the intention of
keeping whatever was down there isolated
from the surface but this was
short-lived after the containment seal
was fitted sight 40 underwent a massive
Communications blackout every device on
site received an email containing a
single image of a large eye taken from a
security camera the text beneath it
simply read found you you some Personnel
who viewed the email underwent anomalous
changes growing new physical features
such as eyes and other various growths
across their body the entirety of site
40-r went offline and the foundation
could not establish contact in an
emergency effort to do so mobile task
force gamma-6 deep feeders was sent to
investigate the task Force's assault on
site-40-r was a daring effort as the
majority of the site was completely
overtaken by tentacles growths and
anomalous alterations while numerous
altered Personnel were lost due to the
mission it was ultimately a success some
altered Personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove
their anomalous growths and after
everything was said and done the site
was repaired and reconstructed without
incident following the site's repair
there has been little activity from The
Entity within the pit but the foundation
continued to keep an eye on the creature
and the ecosystem of the anomalous
marine life that live on the Bass Strait
never knowing what their next move might
be and always keeping in mind the risk
that comes with dealing with these
poorly understood entities a lot of us
have fond memories of Halloween dressing
up in spooky costumes wandering around
the neighborhood with friends while
trick-or-treating getting home with
literal buckets full of candy and then
eating so many sugary treats that you
feel sick Halloween is a beloved holiday
especially throughout many parts of the
United States and if you were lucky
enough to grow up in a town that really
went all out when the last night of
October rolled around then you may have
even had a local Halloween themed
Fairground to visit on the creepiest
night of the year scary rides meses and
jack-o-lanterns as far as the eye can
see but with all that said if you lived
in a certain town in the midwest then
maybe the county fair is a little more
frightening than the spirit of the
Halloween season usually encourages
settle in for a story of scares a tale
of Terror and a fable of Frights this is
scp-097 also known as old Fairgrounds
according off by the SCP Foundation
using huge concrete walls is 10 acres of
rural land in an undisclosed area of the
midwestern United States the place
itself is completely abandoned left
silent and alone as everything contained
within those walls slowly falls into
disrepair this is All That Remains of
the local County Fair held in the year
1969 and right in the middle of it all a
pickup truck crushed and wrecked beyond
all use but this truck didn't crash oh
no this was no tragic roadside accident
the thing that Crush did happen to be a
gigantic pumpkin now we aren't just
talking about a local vegetable growing
Competition winner here when we say this
is a big pumpkin we are talking huge the
Colossal Squad has been recorded to
measure well over seven meters in height
with a diameter just over 8 meters at
the widest point according to estimates
this pumpkin known as
scp-097-1 weighs an enormous 15 000
kilograms or 33 070 pounds to give you a
frame of reference that's about four
times the average weight of a
hippopotamus the pumpkin even manages to
keep a perfectly spherical shape staying
plump and round rather than spreading
out under its own weight as you might
expect a plant of such size would okay a
pickup truck crushed by a giant pumpkin
you might be wondering surely that can't
be all there is well don't you worry
we're just getting started with this
creep show the rest of the surrounding
area of scp-097 is abundant in overgrown
pumpkins none that quite reach the
enviable size of
scp-097-1 but plenty of all different
subspecies and types on average these
smaller our pumpkins weigh around 250
kilograms or 550 pounds along with
various other crops that have grown
within the area of scp-097 the pumpkins
seem to have formed some kind of maze no
pun intended get it maze like corn
these jokes are wasted on you spooky
mazes are no strange inclusion at rural
Halloween fairs like this one getting
lost in the middle of the night
surrounded by rows of corn taller than a
human being is all part of the fun makes
a person feel like they're right in the
middle of a classic 80s slasher movie
where the killer could be creeping up
behind them any second the naturally
formed Labyrinth found within scp-097
has spread all throughout what is left
of the 1969 County Fairgrounds with the
walls of crops reaching over one and a
half meters tall depending on the year
so is that all a maze of crops with one
giant pumpkin at its Center oh that's
far from all there is to scp-097 during
the time between April and November of
every year a number of bizarre and
anomalous phenomenon takes place within
this abandoned County Fairground ranging
from strange happenings that defy
explanation to things that are downright
dangerous since they first came into
contact with scp-097 the foundation have
lost eight agents to this phenomenon
that occur within that area with another
17 being severely maimed while the exact
time of these events seems to vary the
SCP Foundation keeps an extensive record
of phenomena that occur with an
scp-097 now sometimes these will be as
harmless and annoying as the sound of
drums playing throughout the day for
almost 24 hours without stopping then
there's the sightings of entities moving
through the maze only to disappear after
a few short seconds security footage the
foundation agents have gathered of these
entities to pick them as what can only
be described as bed sheet ghosts the
kind you might see and immediately think
of as a last minute low budget Halloween
costume on one particular occasion
singing was heard in the Maze coming
from an unidentified Source when analyze
recordings made by the foundation
revealed that there were up to 30
children's voices all singing in
unintelligible gibberish for three
consecutive hours another incident
involved a member of personnel on site
agent mcroy who cut a pumpkin vine using
a machete horrifyingly the severed Vine
bled by that we mean actual human blood
came pouring out of the plant another
agent on a separate occasion was also
found dead within the scp-097 maze agent
long had disappeared on the way to the
restroom only to be discovered lifeless
and bloodied resting against a pumpkin
during one weekly examination of scp-097
One agent Cole broke open a pumpkin
completely by accident as the pump can
split apart however to the agent's
horror a child's skeleton was revealed
to be inside a human child skeleton a
little girl crouched in the fetal
position believed to only have been
about five years of age another incident
saw O'Toole a research assistant working
on site at scp-097 experiencing symptoms
of nausea O'Toole also appeared to be
vomiting pumpkin seeds despite not
having eaten any recently within a day
O'Toole was dead seeming to have died
overnight in his sleep an autopsy
conducted by Foundation experts revealed
that O'Toole's chest cavity the space
beneath his ribs was somehow filled with
the same pumpkin seeds all of these
happenings are strange to say the least
but perhaps most concerning of all is
the effect that the abandoned Fairground
of scp-097 seems to have on children any
under or up to the age of 10 years old
can fall victim to an unpredictable
signal that seems to emanate from from
scp-097 with a maximum range that is as
of yet undetermined usually beginning in
early April children that are affected
by this signal become Afflicted with
some nompolism or sleepwalking as it is
more commonly known on clear nights
these children will wander around their
own homes often only stopping in front
of closed doorways this Behavior usually
doesn't happen often at least at first
only occurring once a week however
sleepwalking gradually becomes more
frequent and by around the middle of
August it will be a nightly occurrence
if children with this Affliction are
ever woken up while sleepwalking they
will scream for several seconds before
appearing confused this seems to be the
only known way to break the influence of
scp-097 however if left undisturbed a
child will spend their sleepwalking
episodes familiarizing themselves with
the doorways of their house they will
stop at every entrance exit garage door
gate even the neighbor's front doors
once they find a way outside from
September the sleepwalking children will
stay outside upright but asleep until
the sun comes up many are often found
laying on the grass in their Gardens and
commonly recall having dreams about
Autumn season activities between
September 1st and November 1st any
affected child not awoken during their
sleepwalking will begin to migrate
towards
scp-097's location all while still
unconscious they will Traverse County
Roads cutting across large empty Fields
as they gradually make their way towards
the abandoned remains of the County
Fairground once there they will even be
able to blindly navigate a path through
the maze that surrounds most of scp-097
until they find the center what happens
when they make it to the center of the
maze any sleepwalking children who are
able to make it that far will seek out
scp-097-1 the gigantic pumpkin crushing
the truck in the middle of the scp-097
area the children will then sit down
around the almost 23-foot tall pumpkin
and begin to sing even though the SCP
Foundation have managed to make
recordings of this much of the singing
seems to be gibberish or at least not
sung in any known language however music
will also begin playing from an unknown
source seeming to include a number of
basic instruments most commonly simple
drums and pipes after the sleepwalking
children have spent a number of minutes
singing like this that is when things
take a turn for the far far worse like a
Charlie Brown Halloween special straight
out of your most horrific Nightmares
From the Tangled mess of plants that
make up the maze with an scp-097 things
will start to emerge these entities will
crawl out of the surrounding Flora or
will come bursting out from within the
larger of the nearby pumpkins they
appear to be childlike in both their
appearance and mannerisms some even
wearing pajamas or similar clothing why
some simple because these are the
children that sleepwalked before they
are all previous victims the ones stolen
from their families and brought into
this maze still wearing the clothes that
they were last seen in they are all the
children known to be lost to
scp-097 what happens next is truly
chilling the latest child that has been
affected by the draw of the
pumpkin-filled fairground will be
quickly surrounded by all their fellow
victims the other children if they are
in fact still human children will
encircle the newest child singing and
dancing around them in a circle as they
do this a dim light begins to glow from
somewhere within
scp-097-1 the biggest pumpkin in the
center of scp-097 finally at this point
in the process the newly affected child
will wake up normally they experience a
great deal of Terror and confusion after
all they have been unconscious
throughout this entire ordeal
sleepwalking far away from the safety of
their own home to a maze in the middle
of nowhere terror is a powerful thing
enough to make even the bravest person
let out a scream but the moment the now
awakened child lets out any sound that
is when they are doomed should they
scream cry or make any form of vocal
noise then the others will swarm them
the other children the ones previously
lured into a cp097 while sleepwalking
will attack the terrified newcomer each
time is different sometimes they will
clot the new child other times they
might bite or kick the methods are
always different but most often this
swarm of the pumpkin's previous victims
will strangle or dismember the latest
visitor to the abandoned Fairground at
this point there is no saving the latest
victim any attempt to interfere will
only fail either the children will all
become intangible or another violent
phenomenon will occur with an scp-097
stopping any onlooker from saving the
child's life when the deed is finally
done and the latest victim has been
killed by the other children the
gigantic pumpkin at the heart of scp-097
will open its side will split like a
pair of great devouring jaws and the
children will throw the body of the
newest child into
scp-097-1 once the body has been
disposed of these entities wants
children that sleep walked away from
their families will follow crawling into
the pumpkin before it closes and the
music finally stops the exact number of
children between the ages of 3 and 10
years of age who have been lost to
scp-097 is currently kept secret by the
foundation and perhaps for all of our
sanities that is for the best like we
said a lot of us have fond memories of
Halloween but not all of us now go check
out scp-823 Carnival of Horrors and SCP
Hermann Fuller circus of the disquieting
for more creepy carnivals and unsettling
circuses